So, mal gucken, ob das alles soweit funktioniert, ich hoffe schon.
Kurz Vorschau checken, ob ich alles geblört habe, was man blören muss.
Ja, ich hoffe schon.
Ja Leute, wir spielen heute noch ne Runde Dark, quasi so das Game, was ich seit 20
Jahren spiele.
Und nachdem das E-Plus noch heute ungefähr ne Stunde oder so geht, zu Stunde, eineinhalb
Stunden oder irgendwie sowas, muss man mal gucken, hab ich gedacht, ich mach einfach
mal streamen.
Kann ja nix schaden.
Ich hab bisschen Delay drin, geht nicht anders, weil sonst die Gegner unsere Posi sehen.
Ich glaub, das Spiel ist ein bisschen zu dunkel.
Ich mach mal testweise ein bisschen heller, ich hoffe, das reicht.
Es ist gerade Nacht, es ist gerade 3.40 Uhr, es ist relativ dunkel, also insofern Dark
ist ja bekannt dafür, dass es nachts dunkel als fuck ist.
Ja, also, was ich sagen soll, wie gesagt, mit den 5 Minuten Delay seh ich eure Fragen
oder eure Chat-Messages auch ein bisschen später, aber es wäre nicht schlimm, man.
Gürt euch später, seh ich sie, ja, ihr wisst ja.
Wenn ich irgendwas übersehe, schreibt den Wupplos dabei, dann passt das ja.
Und sobald der Stream wirklich live ist, weil, wie gesagt, ich muss jetzt erstmal die 5
Minuten Delay hier auf irgendwas schwätzen, erzähl ich euch ein bisschen was zu dem Game.
Wie gesagt, das ist aus meiner Sicht das beste MMO, was je erfunden wurde, zumindest PVP,
oder besser gesagt, eigentlich muss man sagen RVR, oder wie die coolen Leute sagen, RVR,
das beste PVP-MMO, was es gibt.
Ja, und sobald der Stream live ist, erzähl ich dir noch ein bisschen was zugleich, machen
die Dudes da drüben denn, der Chat ist, der In-Game-Chat ist richtig pepega gerade wieder.
Ihr könnt es nicht sehen, aber er ist wieder richtig pepega.
Moment, falsches Boot, falsches Boot, Kackel.
Da, da müssen wir hin, please, komm, Leute, droppt halt noch ein Boot, meine Güte, so
schwer kann es nicht sein, hier, Boot-Drop, DC wird gefahren, glaube ich, wenn ich das
richtig in Erinnerung habe, was war denn geschrieben?
Ja, ja, passt, alles klar, also, jetzt müsste das Stream aber langsam und sicher mal echt
on kommen, 120 Sekunden, ja, kann ich euch denn erzählen zu dem Game, ich hab's schon
zweimal gestreamt bei mir auf dem Channel, wie gesagt, wenn der Stream richtig on ist
und ich ein Vorschau-Bild hab und der Chat funktioniert, sag ich noch ein bisschen mehr,
ich hab's schon zweimal gestreamt über die letzten paar Jahre über, ich spiele das Spiel
ohne Scheiß seit 2002 oder so, immer wieder mit Unterbrechung und ich hab quasi fast alles
schon mal irgendwie gespielt, außer ich glaub so richtig Heavy Tank mit Schild, Tanks sind
nicht so meins, aber ansonsten hab ich glaub ich alles schon mehr oder weniger durch, also
wenn ihr irgendwas wissen wollt, das ist übrigens ein Free-Shot, also es ist kostenlos, kann
jeder spielen, kurz die Nameplates ein bisschen runter machen, Nameplates, machen wir mal 800
oder so, dass man ein bisschen was sieht, oder ich mach die Nameplates off, so, jetzt noch
eine Minute, ich brauch unbedingt die Stream-Vorschau, dass ich sehe, ob's hell genug ist, ja, ich
nehm' die.
Ja, Dark ist ein, also ausgeschriebener ist das ganze, Dark Edge of Camelot, ist ein MMO
von 2002, hat meiner Meinung nach das beste, mit Abstand, das beste PvP, was es in egal
welchem MMO gibt und das liegt zum kluesten Teil daran, weil du drei verschiedene Reiche
hast, ich bleib jetzt mal kurz an unserer Battle-Group hier gestickt und mach nix, allerweise mach
ich das nicht, weil eigentlich nur Noobs Tunnel Visions sticken, aber ich muss ein bisschen
was erzählen, aber Türmen muss man aufpassen, dass die einem kein Öl auf den Kopf schütten,
ja, also das beste an dem Game, ohne Scheiß, Leute, es gibt, also was es zum besten PvP-Spiel,
besten PvP-MMO aller Zeit macht, du hast drei verschiedene Reiche und mit, glaub ich, jeweils,
hab ich nicht so irgendwie so 12, 13 Klassen in dem Dreh, wirklich für jeden was dabei,
von Damage Caster, Support, Utility Caster, Heiler, Tank, Melee Damage, ist alles dabei.
Und, ja, das beste ist, wie gesagt, es gibt drei Reiche und auch mehrere Gebiete, also
jedes der drei Reiche hat quasi ein spezielles Gebiet, all die Musik willst du jetzt aber
gerade echt wissen, oder?
Ja, also jedes dieser Reiche hat quasi ein spezielles Gebiet, das sieht man hier unten
auch auf der Map, ich hab extra die ganzen Maps offen, normalerweise schieb ich das immer
ein bisschen rum, aber so, kann man, können, denke ich, auch ganz gut was erkennen, also
sprich, jedes Reich hat ein eigenes Grenzgebiet, da geht gerade oben richtig was ab hier, die
hier zum Beispiel, die haben ein eigenes Grenzgebiet und die, also drei verschiedene Reiche, das
ist Hibernia, das ist so Kelten-mäßig angehaucht, dann hast du hier Midgard, das ist ja quasi
eher Schweden und das ist Albion, das ist England, quasi so von der Lore, aber who cares,
ich kenn keine Lore in dem Spiel, ich hab keine Ahnung, ich spiel das Spiel seit 20
Jahren, ich hab absolut null Plan von der Geschichte.
Ah ja, übrigens die Gruppen, übrigens die Gruppen in Darks sind, ich mach mal kurz die
Effekte an, dass ihr seht, was ist für ein Teil, was der Effekt der Clusterfuck ist,
was zockst du da, Dark Age of Camelot Umut, ich hab wie gesagt ja 5 Minuten Delay, Dark
Age of Camelot MMO von 2002, richtig, richtig alter Kram, ja, also richtig auch Massive
Effekt Clusterfuck jetzt, wenn man die Effekte anmacht, oh da kommen Gegners, schlecht, ich
geh mal wieder rein, wo ist er denn, ist er hinterm Turm oder, wo ist er, wo ist unser
Obermalaka, da ist er, da ist er, ja ich versuch euch mal ein bisschen was zu erzählen, also
das ist das Game, was ich quasi abends jetzt von den letzten paar Wochen wieder grinde,
PvP Only oder so, oder fast so, so weit, so weit es möglich ist, PvP Only, sofern was
geht und ich lauf mal hier ein bisschen außerhalb von dem ganzen Zerg, dass ihr euch das ein
bisschen angucken könnt, also das hier sind by the way alles, ich zeig's mal hier, Name
Plates 2000, 2000 Name Plates, das sind alles echte Spieler, also das sind aktuell gerade,
naja ich würd mal sagen 80 Spieler oder sowas, wie gesagt ich hab 5 Minuten Delay, deswegen
kann ich euch so direkt nicht drauf antworten, aber wie gesagt das ist immer noch Dark Age
2 Camelot, bestes PvP MMO aller Zeiten, ja also das sind alles echte Spieler, keine Bots
und irgendwie keine NPCs oder sonst was, naja doch, die Pets hier hinten sind das da, das
da sind, das sind NPCs, also alles was ihr hier seht sind echte Spieler und wir sind
gerade, mal kurz gucken, wir sind gerade 163 Leute, das ist viel, normalerweise ist man
so 70 oder 80 oder sowas in dem Dreh, das ist wirklich viel, also 70 ok, aber 160 ok,
die sind nicht alle hier, aber man sieht schon, guckt euch mal an hier, was da für ein riesen
Wulst sich da lang schiebt, das ist übrigens hier unser Anführer, er hier und normalerweise
bin ich auch im Discord und hör mir so die Kommandos an, die da so rumgeschrien werden,
ich hab euch ja, ich hab euch schon ab und zu erzählt, dass er gerne ein bisschen ausflippt
und jetzt bin ich gerade nicht im Discord, weil ich kann nicht streamen und so und Discord,
da fliegen teilweise die Fetzen, das ist in Grieche und der flamet die Leute immer des
Todes, ja ok, was kann ich euch über das Game erzählen, also wie gesagt das Game muss
ja schon irgendwas haben, wenn mich das 20 Jahre oder so bei der Stange hält, ich spiele
das wie gesagt seit 2002 alle möglichen EU-Server durch, einige US-Server durch und jetzt die
letzten Jahre über eigentlich so gut wie alle Free Shards rauf und runter gespielt, die
es so gibt, übrigens wenn ihr mal lachen wollt, wenn ihr mal mein No-Life sehen wollt, guckt
mal ich hab Played, ich hab gerade, ich hab neun Tage Spielzeit auf dem Character, neun
Tage und der Free Shot ist gestartet glaub am 12.
Dezember oder so, könnt ihr mal ausrechnen, ich hab jeden Tag ein bisschen PvP gecrienet
hier, ja und was ihr hier übrigens gerade seht ist, ich bleib mal draußen, ich bleib
mal draußen, seht ihr gerade nen Turm und zwar seht ihr hier was auch immer wie man
das Ding ausspricht, Dun-Krim-Tain-Tower, was keine Ahnung wie man den genau ausspricht
und es ist folgendermaßen, im gesamten PvP Gebiet sind, also wir sind aktuell hier gerade
da, guck hier oben sind wir da wo alles brennt, ne Schwachsinn da sind wir nicht, wir sind
hier unten und im gesamten PvP Gebiet gibt es Festungen und jede Festung hat vier Türme
und es ist normalerweise so, also das Game hat tatsächlich, auch wenn es vielleicht
auf den ersten Blick ein bisschen sinnloses Rumgezerge aussieht, aber das Game hat noch
deutlich mehr Facetten, das hat tatsächlich eine gewisse Tiefe und da ist vom Einstieg
her auch echt ein bisschen wir, weil es halt eine MMO von 2002 ist und dementsprechend
vieles was die Leute, die mit World of Warcraft und so aufgewachsen sind, halt erkennt nicht
da ist, also es verwirrt wahrscheinlich die meisten Leute so ein bisschen, zumindest
jede Festung im Grenzgebiet, ich kann euch nachher wenn ihr wollt auch mal ein bisschen
Spells und Klassen zeigen, ich stream das hauptsächlich wieder weil ich mir denke vielleicht
haben die ein oder andere Leute auch Bock auf den Free Shard sich das ganze mal anzugucken
und so ne Stunde heute Abend PvP halt dachte ich mir, können wir mal wieder ne Runde streamen,
also jede Festung hat vier Türme und normalerweise können die Gegner von ihrem Außenposten
quasi zu jeder Festung sich hinterleportieren um die zu verteidigen, es sei denn man hat
die Türme vorher eingenommen oder man hat mindestens ein Turm eingenommen, wenn man
ein Turm eingenommen hat, da können die Gegner nicht mehr zur Festung teleportieren und
dann kann man wahrscheinlich die Festung raiden, ich weiß nicht was er vor hat, aber die Festung
jetzt eher nicht, es sind eigentlich viel zu viele Gegner da als dass man jetzt die Festung
irgendwie platt machen könnte, ja Stream Start um die Uhrzeit, wie gesagt ich bin fünf
Minuten hinten dran wegen Delay, dass keiner von den Gegnern aussieht wo wir sind, fünf
Minuten Delay ist eigentlich ausreichend, wir sind grad schon ganz woanders, ich seh
grad die Stream, Leute ist das Game hell genug, ich muss mir das mal mit dem Forscher angucken,
ist das hell genug oder ist das zu dunkel, sagt mir mal was, ich muss es mir mal kurz
auf dem, wo hab ich denn mein Handy, ich muss es mir mal kurz auf dem Handy angucken, weil
wenn das zu dunkel ist, dann mach ich noch ein bisschen heller, das kann nämlich durchaus
sein, ihr müsst mir das mal sagen, ja ja Max ist gut, ein bisschen heller kann es sein
oder, ich frag mal kurz im Chat, ist Helligkeit okay oder ein bisschen heller, weil vielleicht
sollte ich ein Stückchen, ich sollte noch ein Ticken heller machen denke ich mal, was genau
haben wir hier jetzt vor, wir stehen rum okay, glaube ich mach mal ein Ticken heller, ich
glaube ich muss mal ein Ticken heller machen, aber so, ich glaub so ist ganz okay, ja so
ist besser, ja ja seh ich hab schon hier grad meine OBS Vorschau gesehen, hier so ist besser,
also ich bin mir nicht genau sicher was wir hier für Hiveheader Taktiken machen, also
wir stehen hier rum und machen nix okay, tja was kann ich euch sonst noch so erzählen,
also wo war ich denn grad stehen geblieben, oh es geht weiter, ja genau, also wie gesagt
das ist ein äußerst PvP fokussiertes Game, im Endeffekt hast du, oh guck mal Gegner,
wir rennen hier grad sinnlos rum, was für mich ganz gut ist, weil dann kann ich fast
Gegner hauen ab, ja würde ich auch machen, bei 160, bei 160 würde ich mich auch verpissen
mit einer einzelnen Gruppe, ich hoffe und warum ich angemacht hab ist, also wir sind
relativ viele und die Gegner sind auch relativ viele und es gibt immer Epic Fights, da dachte
ich mir, was gibt es bessere Werbung für das Game, als mal ne Runde hier Massen, Massen
PvP, naja die hauen ab, die Gegner werden wir auch nicht erwischen, oh die sind viel
schneller als wir, nicht als ich, aber als der Rest, gibt es nix, ist gut okay, ich hab
es ja so ein bisschen heller gemacht, aber es passt, ja also wie gesagt das Game hat
relativ viele Facetten, also von PvE bis PvP, sogar für Crafter ist es ein ganz gutes
Game, wobei es durchaus spannendere Spiele für Crafter gibt, also du levelst erstmal
deinen Character auf Level 50, Level 50 ist Max und dann guckst du, dass du ein paar Item
farms, dann guckst du, dass du vielleicht ein paar Gegner killst und ein paar Champion
Level machst und dich ordentlich equipst und dann gehst du ins PvP und killst noch mehr
Gegner und das hat relativ viele Facetten das PvP in dem Game, also du kannst das sowohl
wie wir hier in Battle Group spielen, also sprich mit 160 Leuten gegen 100 andere 60
Leute, nachdem die Gruppengröße aber 8 Leute umfasst, was mehr ist als die meisten modernen
MMOs haben übrigens, die meisten modernen MMOs haben irgendwie was um 5, so in dem Dreh,
irgendwie so in dem Dreh will ich sagen, also Final Fantasy hat auf jeden Fall 5 und ich
glaube War hat auch 5 und das sind 8, hat Vor- und Nachteile, 8er Groups, ich persönlich
mag es, weil es irgendwie mehr Facetten hat, du kannst 2-3 Supporter dabei haben, du kannst
Tanks mit Nahkampfdamage, ranged, Casterdamage, finde ich persönlich ein bisschen angenehmer
als 5, natürlich ist es in 5er Gruppe in anderen MMOs deutlich einfacher zu organisieren,
als eine 8er Gruppe in Dark, wir sind aktuell hier gerade von den Leuten in der 8er Gruppe
sind wir quasi 6 Leute, wir spielen öfters zusammen, also er, sie, er, er, sie und ich,
wir spielen öfters zusammen, wir haben noch 2 random Leute heute dabei, einfach weil wir
nicht 8 Leute aufgefüllt haben bekommen, von welchen die öfters mitspielen, ja ich würde
es euch jetzt gerne mal ein paar Fights zeigen, bevor wir immer im Kreis rennen, aber aktuell
geht gerade nicht so viel, außer dass wir mit 160 Leuten im Kreis rennen und ich mal
nicht direkt mit in diesem Pulk rennen, dass man ein bisschen was sieht, ja wie gesagt
also das PvP hat relativ viele Facetten, du hast auch mehrere Grenzgebiete, wo du Festungen
erobern kannst und dich mit Feinden kloppen kannst, du kannst entweder mit kleiner Gruppenanzahl
spielen, also entweder mit 8, mit 8 Leuten kannst du gut spielen, du kannst auch mit
1 bis 4 Leuten gut spielen, gibt es beispielsweise PvP Quests oder ein extra Gebiet, wo sich
Gruppen kloppen können und es gibt halt insgesamt 3 große RVR Gebiete, also 3 große PvP Gebiete,
oh, oh, Gegners, ja 3 Gegners alter, guckt euch das mal, das ist ja nix, einfach mal
drüber gerutscht mit 160 Leuten, was ist das für eine Völkerwanderung, das nennt man
in diesem Spiel Farchagor, das nennt sich ein Zerg, na gut wo das herkommt ist klar
aus StarCraft, aber uns triffts glaube ich auch ganz gut, das ist richtige Völkerwanderung
mit 160 Leuten, oh guckt mal noch, ne, sind da, alter können wir mal, oh, oh, paar Gegners,
auf gehts, bashen, die sind ja schon alle down wieder, geil, das macht jetzt keine Werbung
für jeden Mann, alles dead, alles schon dead, ich hab eigentlich extra gewartet bevor ich
angemacht hab, ich hab schon eine halbe Stunde gespielt und hab extra gewartet und hab gewartet
bis es ein paar gescheite Fights gab und als wir ein paar gescheite Fights hatten hab ich
gedacht ich mach jetzt mal den Stream an, aber irgendwie ist es jetzt grad nix mehr, willst
du machen?
Wird schon, wird schon, früher oder später, ja wie gesagt, also du hast dann, du kannst
fast mit 1 bis 4 Leuten machen, also wenn ihr bloß mit ein paar Freunden spielen wollt
gibt es genug zu tun, du kannst mit 8 Leuten spielen gegen andere 8er oder halt versuchen
ob du auch noch mehr killen kannst, du kannst im Battlecube spielen, es gibt ein, es gibt
2, stimmt eigentlich gar nicht, es gibt 2 pvp Dungeons, einen großen für alle Reiche und
quasi 3 kleinere mit einem zentralen Bereich, also du hast gerade im pvp Bereich gibt es
eigentlich nix was irgendwie auch nur ansatzweise an der Ork rankommt, gut das ist jetzt grad
ein bisschen schlecht zu sehen weil eigentlich nix passiert, aber gut, wir eigentlich hauptsächlich
im Kreis rennen, aber was willst du tun würde als der echte Gangster zu sagen, kannst du
nix machen, die guten All-NR-Feuerzeiten, Namen wieder ausblenden, ich hab die Namen
ehrlich gesagt ganz gerne an, vielleicht nicht auf 2000er range, weil man teilweise die Leute
einfacher über den nametag anklicken kann als auf den body, weil Darklogik, namplates,
machen wir mal auf 800 wieder runter, ist nicht ganz so krass, Bildschirm voller Namen, ja
du hast, ich versuche einfach ein bisschen was über das Game zu erzählen bis was passiert,
ja also du hast wie gesagt 3 verschiedene Reiche in denen du spielen kannst und du hast
glaube ich so um die 13 Klassen pro Realm ungefähr, pro Reich, da ist wirklich alles
dabei, also wir spielen hier gerade Midgard, also das was so quasi mittelalterliches Schweden
so ein bisschen nach erfunden ist, so mit Thor und Odin und alle möglichen Zeug, da ist
halt alles verschneit zum größten Teil, ja heute richtig oldschool unterwegs, guck mal
ein paar Gegner, aber da kommen wir wieder nicht hin und von den Spiele-Designern ist
Midgard eigentlich so als Nahkampfreich gedacht, so nach dem Motto du hast dort mehr Tanks
und mehr Nahkampfklassen als überall anders, was so gar nicht genau stimmt, aber die Designer
haben sich gedacht ja Midgard so Nordmänner und sowas, das ist so das Nahkampfreich,
das Problem ist nur, dass die, also Balance in Dark ist so ein Thema und guck mal noch
ein paar Gegner wieder, tatsächlich, deadge, alle schon wieder dead, achja man kann übrigens
auch tauchen wenn man will, aber da gibt es meistens nichts großartiges zu sehen, übrigens
hier oben sehen wir mal 160 Leute, 160 Leute auf einmal offen, ja also Balance in Dark ist
so ein Thema für sich, ja, also die Designer haben sich so ein paar Sachen gedacht, die
haben, ja so aus heutigen Gesichtspunkten haben die mehr schlecht als recht funktioniert,
zum Beispiel haben die sich gedacht, hey Midgard so Nordmänner und sowas, das ist so das Nahkampfreich,
Problem ist nur, oder ich erzähle euch das erstmal fertig, was die sich dabei gedacht
haben und dass es nicht wirklich funktioniert, die haben sich gedacht, ja Midgard, also die
mit dem Hammer, das ist so das Nahkampfreich und die Berner, das sind die mit dem Baum,
das ist quasi so das Magie- und Casterreich und heute wäre Berner glaube ich voll angesagt
so für Naturliebhaber und Veganer oder so, ja und Albion hast du dann quasi so Richtung
König, Artus und Ritter und Plattenrüstung und sowas, zumindest es funktioniert nicht
so ganz, man hat zwar versucht Schwerpunkte zu setzen bei den Designern für die verschiedenen
Reiche, aber im Endeffekt musstest du allen Reichen ungefähr die gleichen Fähigkeiten
geben und das lief dann darauf raus, dass du dann gesagt hast, aha, dass die Designer gesagt
haben, aha, Midgard ist das Nahkampfreich, die kriegen irgendwie ganz viele tolle Nahkampfcharaktere
und zwei oder eins, zwei richtige Casterklassen und du musstest dann halt auf die Caster alle
Fähigkeiten verteilen, das läuft darauf raus, dass Midgard zumindest was Supporter angeht
eigentlich, Supporter und Caster so komplett vollgeklatschte Klassen hat, weil sie das
was in Albion beispielsweise auf vier Klassen verteilt haben, Midgard auf zwei Klassen verteilt
haben, also Design und Dark ist so, Balance und Dark ist nicht so das, wobei man sagen
muss, ihr könnt fast alles spielen in dem Game, also falls irgendjemand Bock hat, falls
irgendjemand Bock hat oder noch Bock bekommen sollte, ich zeige euch mal kurz die Webseite,
also falls irgendjemand kostenlos spielen möchte auf Eden, wie gesagt Eden ist ein Dark-Free-Shot,
das ist nicht der offizielle Server, aktuell spielen gerade ungefähr 2900 Leute, was vollkommen,
was eine wirklich absolut super Spieleranzahl ist für einen Dark-Server, es ist nicht zu
viel, es ist nicht zu wenig, es war schon manchmal ein bisschen viel, aber insgesamt ist wirklich
ganz toll, auch sehr ausgeglichen, jetzt reichen ungefähr gleich viel, wir haben ein bisschen
weniger, also wer spielen will, sollte sich das mal auf der Homepage angucken, gibt eigentlich
für PvP kein besseres und ihr könnt, wenn ihr was spielen wollt, ihr könnt prinzipiell
alles spielen, was ihr wollt, also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass man sagt, man muss unbedingt
hier einen dieser drei Metaklassen spielen oder so, du kannst gerade, wenn du in BG,
also hier mit mehreren Leuten spielst, kannst du quasi alles spielen, es gibt halt schon
ein paar Klassen, wenn du es optimiert machen willst, die sind jetzt nicht ganz so geil,
aber die haben es ganz gut hingekriegt mittlerweile, du kannst alles spielen, okay vielleicht außer
Champions, Champions sagt ein bisschen, aber sonst kannst du fast alles spielen und eine
wirkliche Eigenheit von Dark ist, dass alle drei Reiche komplett, wirklich komplett, nicht
so Alibi-mäßig, wie das am Anfang in World of Warcraft war, so irgendwie jedes Reich,
quasi eine Spezialklasse oder sowas, also alle drei Reiche sind in Dark Age of Camelot komplett
unterschiedlich, die haben unterschiedliche Grenzgebiete, die haben unterschiedliche,
ja quasi Heimatgebiete, also jedes Reich hat eigene Gebiete, hat alles komplett eigene
Klassen, es gibt nichts doppelt, also wenn ihr sagt, ich gehe jetzt nach Albion und mach
mir da einen Character, was ich euch auf dem Server nicht empfehlen würde, irgendwie sacken
die Alps ein bisschen, zur Zeit zumindest, zur Zeit, wobei heute Abend haben sie uns
schon gut zerlegt, oh guck mal, auf gehts, Festung, Raid, Attacke, jetzt muss man ein
bisschen aufpassen, ich werde das gleich fortführen mit den Klassen, das ist eine Festung von
den Gegnern, das erkennt man daran, also eine HIP Festung, das erkennt man daran, dass es
auf der Map grün ist und wenn man das anklickt, die Festung auch so den Hibernia Style hat,
wobei ich weiß gar nicht, ob die Optik wechselt, ne die Optik wechselt nicht, erzähl Blödsinn,
wechsel überhaupt nicht, oder wechsel die, warte ich bin verwirrt, wechsel die Keep Optik,
nachdem er das, ich hab mir das gar nicht genau angeguckt hier, was auch immer, zumindest
man sieht es auf der Map, man sieht es auf der Map, dass es grün ist und wir haben jetzt,
vorher haben wir den Turm hier hererobert, das heißt die Gegner können sich nicht mehr
in die Festung teleportieren, um die zu verteidigen, das heißt wir haben jetzt ein paar Ramm aufgestellt
und ich bin nicht im Discord, aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, er schreit schon wieder rum,
dass alle in die Rammen sollen und gefälligst, und gefälligst das Tor kaputt machen sollen.
Gut, ich setz mich mal in die Ramme und ramme ne Runde, Gatschi-Buzz, so, eine gefährliche
Sache, wenn man, moin Leute, eine gefährliche Sache, wenn man keeps raided, richter Kreise
grind, wenn man keeps raided, ich geh mal aus der Ramme, dass wir es sehen, die Gegner
können einem natürlich die ganze Zeit in den Rücken fallen, also von allen Seiten und
die lassen sich normalerweise auch die Festung nicht so gerne abnehmen, deswegen muss man
ein bisschen sich umgucken, also ich wurde schon total oft gegangt von der Seite, wo
wir versucht haben, irgendwelche Festungen zu erobern, wofür ist der Delay?
Der Delay ist dafür da, dass die Gegner nicht sehen, wo wir sind, weil das, ich mein ich
hab die Maps auf, du siehst überall wo wir sind, und du kannst in dem Game durch Position
extrem viel ausgleichen.
Also gerade in BG-Fights, den wir hoffentlich demnächst nochmal einen ordentlichen größeren
Fight haben, in BG-Fights ist Position und, wie soll man das sagen, so Flow von dem Fight
eigentlich das A und O, am Ende gewinnt vielleicht im Durchschnitt doch der, der die meisten
Spieler hat, aber das muss nicht unbedingt immer so sein, also du kannst ohne Probleme
mit 80 Mann, also im BG-Fight, wenn größere Anzahl von Spieler gegen größere Anzahl
von Spieler kämpfen, kannst du ohne Probleme mit 80, 120, 130 killen, wenn du die richtige
Position hast, wenn du das Gebiet ausnutzt, wenn du beispielsweise die Sichtlinien durch
brichst, weil du hinter den Berg gehst, und also gerade wenn du die gegnerische BG so
schräg von der Seite erwischst und sowas, da hast du eigentlich, da hast du schon 30
Gegner down, bevor die überhaupt checken, dass du überhaupt gerade 30 Gegner geschnetzelt
hast, also BG-Fights ist Menge tatsächlich nicht alles, und ich hoffe ich kann euch das
zeigen wie das mit so einem Keep funktioniert, also so eine Festung hat zwei Türen, die kann
man auframpen, oder die kann man einhauen, einschlagen kann man die Türen jetzt relativ
schwierig bei dem, weil das ihr seht, das ist lila, und lila heißt das Keep ist aufgelevelt
auf 10, 10er Keeps macht man kaum Schaden mit der Waffe am Tor, so und innerhalb von
so einer Festung kann man halt hoch und kann dann warten bis die Gegner reinkommen und
die Gegner killen, oder man ist möglichst schnell und macht das innere Tor auf, weil
jede Festung hat einen Boss oben, hier da oben im Turm steht der Boss, hier so ungefähr
steht der, da können wir gleich rein, wenn wir das Tor offen haben, da ist ein Boss drinnen,
und wenn man den Boss killt, dann gehört einem die Festung, dann werdet ihr sehen gleich,
sofern unsere Leute nicht sterben, dann werdet ihr gleich sehen, das Keep wird von da auf
der Map von grün zu blau, und dann gehört es uns, und wenn man den Keep besitzt hat
einige Vorteile, hauen wir ab, oder was, oder kommen Gegner, ich weiß nicht, ich bleib
hier einfach mal, ich setz mich mal in die Ramme und mach weiter, Hyper Gachi auf die
Tür, Tür, Keep Gate, 290%, oh das wird knapp, also die Gegner sind bestimmt schon auf dem
Weg, müssen wir gucken, dass wir schnell ins Keep reinkommen, sonst wird das nix, übrigens,
ich kann es an der Stelle mal anmerken, alles echte Spieler, keine Bots oder sonst was,
das einzige was quasi NPCs sind, sind hier die Pets von dem Typ zum Beispiel, aber alles
was sich hier bewegt und Name über dem Kopf hat, ist ein echter Spieler, er regt sich
in der BG gerade wieder richtig auf, dass die Leute sacken, hat auch recht, wir können
auch ein bisschen aufs Tor schlagen, ja, wofür das Delay ist, naja, wir spielen gerade
PvP, so du siehst wir sind hier im PvP Gebiet, gerade dort oben links oben am Rande der Map,
und es gibt zwei gegnerische Reiche, die wahrscheinlich nicht wollen, dass wir in die Festung einnehmen,
das heißt, wenn die sehen, dass wir das machen, dann kommen die alle relativ schnell, normalerweise
merken die das erst, wenn das anfängt auf der Map zu brennen, wenn die natürlich bei
mir im Stream sehen, dass ich da hin renne 5 Minuten oder 10 Minuten vorher, dann ist
das natürlich ein bisschen unfair auch jetzt für die anderen Leute, die hier mitspielen,
das Spiel hat übrigens keine DLCs und keinen Battle Pass und nix, ich hoffe es gibt noch
richtig gute Fights, ich hab extra gewartet, bis wir zwei, drei richtig fette Fights gerade
hatten, bevor ich umgelockt hab und den Stream angemacht hab, aber nope, no Pass, gibt nix,
und ich muss euch sagen, also ich spiele das seit 2002 und ich hab das seit 20 Jahren immer
wieder mit Abständen zwischendrin gespielt, erst live, dann Free Shots, alles mögliche,
ich glaube ich hab in keinem anderen Spiel so viele In-Game-Stunden wie in Dark, also
ich kann es doch nicht mal irgendwie ansatzweise schätzen, wie viele In-Game-Stunden ich da
hab, ich hab bestimmt die In-Game-Stunden, kann man nicht rechnen, In-Game-Jahre hab
ich wahrscheinlich, ich meine, ich spiele das seit über 10 Jahren, ich hab bestimmt
ein Jahr schon komplett in Dark verbracht meines Lebens oder sowas, ist wahrscheinlich
gar nicht zu sehr zu untertrieben, ja, achso es hat, ach übrigens, ich zeige euch gleich
mal was, wir können ein bisschen die Optik tunen von dem Game, passt mal auf, müsst ihr
mir sagen, ob es dann besser aussieht, wie ihr das empfindet, ich finde es sieht viel
besser aus, wenn ich die Optik, ich mach gleich mal die Effekte an, übrigens wundert euch
nicht, hier blickt man nicht durch, was gerade passiert, das hier ist ein Boss irgendwo,
guckt mal, irgendwo hier ist ein Boss, den wir gerade killen und jetzt gehört uns, jetzt
gehört uns die Festung, weil wir gerade den Boss gekillt haben, das Game ist von 2001
in US und ich glaube 2002 in EU, so, hallo, die Tür klitscht, ok, pass mal auf, ich mach
jetzt mal kurz die Effekte an, ich hab hier nämlich so ein Zusatzplugin, mach mal Effekte
an, ja, sieht deutlich farbenfroher und besser aus oder, mit Effekten an, viel besser, viel
besser und auch alles ein bisschen schärfer und so, viel besser, viel besser, guckt mal
wie viele Leute man, schaut euch das mal an und ungefähr so ein großer Pulk rennt
von den anderen zwei Reichen auch rum und jetzt, seht ihr, guckt, die Festung ist blau,
das heißt, die haben wir gerade eingenommen, habt ihr gerade gesehen, wir haben gerade den
Boss gekillt, oben von der Festung und wenn wir jetzt diese vier Türme einnehmen, die
zu dieser Festung gehören, also quasi der Turm, der Turm und äh, warte mal, vier, drei,
oder?
Ich glaube es sind sogar nur drei, drei Türme, ach, keine Ahnung, ja, ich glaube es sind
sogar nur drei Türme, ich erzähl, Mist, ähm, wenn wir die hier einnehmen, lässt du den
Stream als Watt, vielleicht, ja, wahrscheinlich, ich lass eigentlich alle Streams als Watt,
so, und wenn wir das hier, wenn wir das hier eingenommen haben, dann können wir jetzt hierhin
porten, also sprich, wir haben jetzt quasi eine Basis im, im gegnerischen Realm, weil
wir haben die Festung eingenommen, wusste, wir haben die Türme eingenommen, das heißt,
wir können jetzt quasi von unserem Außenposten bei uns daheim hierhin teleportieren, was
natürlich super für Nachschub ist und warum macht man das Ganze, also sprich, warum macht
man PvP, was ist der Anreiz in dem Game, ich mein, irgendwie müssen die Leute ja auch
Bock drauf haben, außer dass es Bock macht, Gegner zu killen und PvP zu spielen, was sind
die Anreize, gut, du hast deinen Character, den levelst du bis 50, dann schaust du, dass
du ordentliches Equipment, ordentliche, ordentliche, dass du deine Stats hier ordentlich gecapped
hast und alles, und wenn du PvP machst, warum bist du das richtige Spiel eingestellt, ja,
und wenn du PvP machst, dann kannst du Realm Points sammeln und von diesen Realm Points
kannst du dann spezielle, achso und du machst Bounty Points, von denen kannst du dir auch
irgendwelche Dinger kaufen, aber du bekommst Realm Points und von den Realm Points kannst
du dir spezielle Fähigkeiten kaufen, kann zum Beispiel mal den Trainerdialog aufmachen,
da werdet ihr sehen, das ist, ist schon relativ komplex das Game, also das ist normale, normale
Skills, ich bin übrigens wahrscheinlich der einzige Skull, der auf diesem Server, der
Schwerd gespeckt hat, Schwerd ist mit Abstand die schlechteste, die schlechteste Waffenspeck,
die man, die man machen kann, also wenn ihr das Game spielen solltet, dann speckt vor
allem mit Midgard nicht Schwerd, Schwerd ist einfach nur kacke, aber ich mag Schwerd,
Alter wie viele Leute, man sieht nix, ja und was man noch machen kann ist, was so ein bisschen
die Long Term Procretion ist, wenn man das so schön nennt, wenn ich jetzt mal hier den
Train Dialog aufmache, seht ihr, ich kann hier von RAs Zeug kaufen, es gibt hier ganz
viele Fähigkeiten, die kann ich mir nur durch PvP Punkte kaufen und das sind zum Teil mit
die stärksten Fähigkeiten, die es in diesem Game gibt, also jede Klasse hat eine Spezialfähigkeit
und ein paar ausgewählte, die nicht so viele andere Klassen haben, aber jede Klasse hat
eigentlich ein paar richtige OP Fähigkeiten, äh hallo, guck mal ein paar Gegner, endlich
Leute, aber sind alle schon dead wieder, deadge, guck mal alles tot, das ist übrigens auch
so ne OP Fähigkeit hier, das stunt einfach alle im Umkreis, ich muss die Nameplates,
wieder, wieder anmachen, weil ansonsten sieht man nix, seh ich auch nicht wo Gegner sind
gescheit, mach die wieder auf 2000, ich hab die nicht immer auf 2000, seitdem das geht,
ist Mr. aus Camlond keine Ahnung, den hab ich heute zum ersten Mal in der Group, ja
wie gesagt, also das was man von sich, von diesen PvP Punkten freischalten kann, sind
so mit die, mit, nicht unbedingt zwangsläufig, aber mit die stärksten Fähigkeiten im gesamten
Team, zum Beispiel, ich versuch euch das mal grob zu erklären, was, was es bei mir ist,
zwar, ich mach mal kurz Train auf, ähm, ich hab aktuell nicht so viele Sachen, ich
hab einmal das hier, ignoriert's erstmal, und dann hab ich so meine Spezialität, was
quasi pro, pro Realm nur eine Klasse kaufen kann, ist Speed of Sound, was dafür sorgt,
dass mich keiner aus dem Speed, also dass unsere gesamte Gruppe niemand aus dem Speed
hauen kann, also wir rennen jetzt ja schneller als normal, ihr seht's ja, wir sind schneller,
normale, normale Geschwindigkeit ist ungefähr so, und für 10 Sekunden kann uns keiner,
oder ich glaub sogar für 20 Sekunden, kann uns keiner aus dem Speed hauen, das ist extrem
OP, sobald wir Damage machen geht das weg, aber zum, zum Flüchten und zum Reinpushen
und so ist das die beste, beste Fähigkeit, die es gibt in dem Spiel, und es gibt noch
ein paar andere Sachen, ich kann zum Beispiel so eine, so eine Heilfähigkeitsbecken und
so ein paar andere Zeug, also wie gesagt, also die Realm Points und die Fähigkeiten
dafür sind quasi so das, was den Character auch über, über die Spielzeit immer, immer
besser werden lässt, und es ist ein richtiger, also es ist wirklich großer Unterschied, ob
du einen Character hast, der quasi erst 50 geworden ist, und noch kaum PvP gespielt
hat, oder ob du einen hast, der schon, ich kann es euch ja mal zeigen, Sekunde, oder
ob du einen Character hast, der schon irgendwie Realm Rank 7, 8 oder sowas ist, also du fängst
an mit 1l1, und irgendwie es geht dann, es geht bis 11, und das nimmt aber so exponentiell
zu, was du an Punkten für brauchst, es ist ein riesen Unterschied, also soweit, dass
du die, dass du das gar nicht wirklich vergleichen kannst, also in der Regel ist es so, dass
ein frisch 50 gewonnener von einem 1l1er sowas von weggesnackt wird, da hast du eigentlich
gar keine Chance, allein wenn du die ganzen passiven Fähigkeiten, die du dazu kaufen
kannst.
Tja, und ansonsten, wie gesagt, falls einer, falls einer ist in den Fingern juckt, dass
er mal ausprobieren will, könnt ihr auf die Eden-Webseite gehen, euch das installieren
und kostenlos ausprobieren, ihr könnt eigentlich spielen, was ihr wollt, um mal da anzusetzen,
da wollte ich vorher auch schon was zu sagen, ihr könnt eigentlich, gerade wenn ihr so
auf so Large Scale PvP steht, könnt ihr eigentlich nahezu alles spielen, es gibt ein paar Klassen,
die sind natürlich gefragter als andere, aber ihr solltet erstmal das spielen, worauf
ihr Bock habt, das ist tatsächlich das Beste, es gibt eigentlich kaum Klassen, die man
so hier in diesem Battle Group PvP nicht gebrauchen kann, die taugen alle irgendwie.
Ich persönlich spiele es gerne ein bisschen optimierter, gerade auch was Battle Group
Compositions angeht, da kann man sich jetzt streiten, was gute Gruppenzusammensetzungen
sind, was schlechte Gruppenzusammensetzungen sind, also was sich bewährt hat, ich kann
euch ja mal kurz erzählen, warum unsere Gruppe so aussieht, wie sie aussieht, also was sich
bei uns bewährt hat, ist, wir spielen immer Triple Support, heißt zwei Heiler, Shani haben
wir immer dabei, den anderen hier haben wir heute das erste Mal dabei, zwei Heiler und
einen Shammy, wo ist er, da, Triple Support, sprich wir haben ordentlich Heals, wir haben
ordentlich Buffs, dass wir mehr Damage machen und wir haben auch noch ganz gut Damage, weil
der Shammy kann auch noch Gegner vergiften und sowas, korrekt, deswegen ist Delay, genau,
also wir spielen Triple Support, dann haben wir zwei Tanks, zwei Hybride Tanks, die sowohl
Nahkampfdamage als auch Rangedamage machen können, die die beste Realmfähigkeit im gesamten
Spiel haben, deswegen doppelt und noch zwei Rangedcasters, nämlich einmal einen Runenmeister
und einmal einen Bone Dancer, der Bone Dancer hat die zweitbeste Reichsfähigkeit, die es
gibt, die brauchst du eigentlich immer und der Runi ist für AE Damage und AE Damage
ist das, oh jetzt gibt's Special Tactics, MonkaS, Special Tactics, Alter, die Wikinger kommen,
guck jetzt können sie uns nicht unterbrechen was Damage angeht, was Speed angeht durch
meine Fähigkeit, das war keine, Alter, Effekte aus, Effekte aus, Effekte aus, Effekte aus,
Police Effekte aus, das Game ruckelt, ok, jetzt gibt's auf den Sack gleich, MonkaS,
schon der erste LD, schon der erste LD, ich hab gar keine Ahnung, ok, übrigens das mit
dem roten, mit dem roten Zeug über dem Kopf, wer hätte sich das gedacht, Alter, ich blick
hier nicht durch, das laggt, ich hab ein 13.900k, Alter, und es laggt immer noch, gehen wir
raus, oder was, wieder, wir gehen glaub ich wieder raus, ich blick's nicht, das war ja
mal ganz, ganz Cringe Charge, einmal heilen, wer, wer ist denn rausgeflogen, oh ich glaub
unser Heiler ist rausgeflogen, hat zu sehr geruckelt, was war denn das, Alter, ich bin
reingepusht, und dann war ich fast dead, was soll ich machen, ok, jetzt kriegen wir wahrscheinlich
auf den Sack, hätte nicer fight werden können, würde es aber nicht, so wir sollten jetzt
einfach alle sterben und regroupen, die pushen uns jetzt eh gleich, guck, alles stirbt, Gegner,
deswegen ist immer, so ein bewachtes Keep zu Chargen ist wirklich fragwürdig, also da
kriegst du eigentlich in der Regel immer auf den Sack, rennen wir mal weg, Alter, das sind
ja genauso nassen wie wir, ich geh mich jetzt, ich geh mich jetzt walten, ich renn jetzt
in die Gegner rein, hallo Gegners, Achtung Ubo-Taktik, Ubo-Taktik, der da, der muss jetzt
an glauben, Bam, Deadge, ich hab übrigens die Effekte ausgemacht, weil es zu sehr geruckelt
hat, so jetzt müssen die Leute mal ein bisschen auffüllen in der Group, ja, das ist der Greis
im Livestream, korrekt, ich hab mittlerweile schon, ich hab's schon wieder vergessen,
neun Tage oder so Playtime, neun Tage, also echte Tage, ich spiele seit neun Tagen, neun
Tage Playtime, seit glaub ich 12.
Dezember oder so, wann das on gegangen ist, also wer auch Bock hat zu spielen, wie gesagt
einfach hier dark-eden.net, hier oben gibt's dann irgendwo how to play, müsst ihr euch
das Spiel runterladen, patchen und auf geht's, wir sollen wieder zurück, jetzt habt ihr
es gesehen, jetzt kann ich direkt zu den Gegnern porten, weil wir die Türme eingenommen haben
eben und wir müssen Group auffüllen, am besten noch ein bisschen Range Damage, ja ich zeig
euch nochmal kurz die Skills, also wie gesagt das ist das was man vom normalen Leveln kriegt,
jede Klasse hat so drei bis fünf Skillbäume, die kann man unterschiedlich und es gibt
natürlich wahnsinnig viele Skillungen pro Klasse, ja also in der Regel kannst du so
drei wirklich gute Skillungen pro Klasse gibt es aber mehr auch nicht, du kannst die Punkte
zwar frei verteilen aber es macht nicht so wirklich Sinn vieles, deswegen habe ich im
Endeffekt übrigens meine Skillung ist nicht gut sag ich gleich, also wer Skaldes spielen
will sollte nicht diese Skillung nehmen, ich hab 34 Schwert, sollte man eher 39 machen
und schon gar nicht Schwertspecken, sondern eher Hammer wenn man 39 skillen will, aber
letztendlich wir wollen ja nicht in die Details zu zählen, die Details gehen und halt eigentlich
die Skilllinie die meine Klasse ausmacht, gibt nicht so viele Möglichkeiten, gibt meistens
so zwei drei verschiedene Skillmöglichkeiten pro Klasse, entweder wenn es eine reine Damage
Klasse ist worauf man Wert legen will oder dann halt manchmal auch so eine Sache mit will
man Damage machen, will man eher Support spielen oder möchte man eine Klasse eher so auf so
Hybrid mäßig auslegen, ja meistens gibt es drei, zwei, drei vielleicht auch vier gute
Specs, oh Gegner tatsächlich wir haben ein paar gefunden, der Rest ist jetzt also leveln
bis 50 ist eigentlich relativ straight forward, 40 90 und es lag, Leute dieses Spiel bringt
den besten PC in die Knie mit 160 versus 160, ohne Scheiß, also Dark ist auch nicht multithreaded
oder maximal Dual Core ausgelastet, ja also maximal zwei Kerne, Dark bringt den besten
und krassesten PC zum laggen, ich habe leider keine FPS Anzeige gerade, guck mal, ne ich
kann ja auch nicht einplanten, Mist, keine FPS Anzeige aber ist ohne Mist, also Dark bringt
den allerbesten besten PC zum glühen, immer noch, wisst ihr wie man dieses Spiel gespielt
hat 2002, ich zeige euch mal, ich zeige euch, das Spiel hat man so gespielt 2002, guck,
so, ohne Scheiß, man ist 2002 so rumgelaufen, wenn viele Leute da waren, weil es so krass
geruckelt hat, guck mal, wenn ich hier die Spieler ins Bild bringe, dann droppt es gleich
auf 20 FPS runter, ich habe ein 13.900K ohne 40 90 und es lag trotzdem, schon krass oder,
oh Gegner, Bastion, einmal drauf gehitted, direkt down, also wie gesagt, sucht euch, falls
jemand Bock drauf hat, sucht euch einen Reich aus, wo ihr spielen wollt, sucht euch ne Klasse
oder besser gesagt, guckt einfach mal durch, sucht euch ne Klasse aus, die ihr gerne spielen
wollt und dann guckt euch einfach mal an, das Leveln ist auf dem Server relativ easy,
das haben die wirklich gut gemacht, 3rd Magic Eye fragt gerade, das muss ich mir mal durchlesen,
wir sollten mal unsere Crew wieder auffüllen, wir brauchen noch ein bisschen AE Leute, bam,
bam, bam, bam, mit 7 Leuten ist das nicht optimist, es ist etwas ungewohnt mit der Zauberleiste
oben links, haben die Zauber auch sowas wie Abklingzeiten und wenn ja, werden diese angezeigt,
ja hier zum Beispiel, guck, noch 2 Minuten 15, das ist gerade down, das UI ist halt pre
World of Warcraft era, das MMO UI ist so, oh ne, please, nicht nochmal, nicht nochmal
keep charge, nein, nicht nochmal, please, nicht nochmal wippen, das ist übrigens, ich
hab gerade 5 FPS oder sowas, in dieses Feld sollte man übrigens nicht rein, weil kriegt
man Damage und wird langsamer, also bisschen ausweichen und wer jetzt denkt, fuck wer soll
da durchblicken bei den ganz vielen Effekten, keiner, niemand, ich kann euch so grob sagen,
was passiert, aber nicht wirklich, was im Detail passiert, außer dass sie gerade Damage bekommen
da hinten und ich mal ein bisschen zurückbleibe, weil ich sonst instant gebashed werde, wenn
ich aufpasse, komm ich setz mal, ich setz mal was für die ganzen Heiler zum wrecken, Lagerfeuer,
also die Zauber haben Abklingzeiten, ja nicht alle, also die hier, so super, die wirklich
starken Fähigkeiten haben meistens einen Cooldown, ansonsten haben die ganzen Zauber
eigentlich nur Castspeed und keinen Cooldown, also du kannst zum Beispiel, ich hab auch
so einen billig, warte mal, ich hab auch so einen mini, mini Cast, so mini, mini Damage,
boah ich hab grad nix wo ich draufcasten kann, das könnt ich euch zeigen, also die
ganzen Zauber haben normalerweise kaum einen Cooldown, die haben aber einen Castspeed,
der dazu gehört, also sprich wenn ein Zauber einen Castspeed von 2 Sekunden hat, musst
du halt 2 Sekunden casten, ohne dass du unterbrochen wirst.
Und in DAOG wirst du bei jedem Cast unterbrochen, sobald du Damage kriegst, also wer meint als
Caster da rumstehen zu können und permanent DPS zu spammen geht nicht, weil sobald du
Damage kriegst, hörst du auf zu casten, guck, der jetzt kriegt Damage, der kriegt jetzt
gleich auf den Sack da oben, also du musst dich wirklich gut platzieren und in DAOG ist
es so, dass du gar nicht so sehr sagen kannst, was jetzt den krasseren Damage macht, das
ist sehr situationsabhängig, pauschal kann man sagen, ja Caster, also Zauberer, wobei
dass er klasse in dem Spiel ist, machen den meisten Damage, aber gerade wenn viel abgeht,
ist Nahkampf auch nicht zu verachten, weil Nahkampf kann nicht unterbrochen werden, Zauberer
werden durch jeglichen Damage unterbrochen, Nahkampf nicht, also ich kann so lange drauf
hauen, wie ich lebe, Zauberer können aber nicht so lange zaubern, wie sie wollen, so
eine Runde Belagerungsmaschinen ausgepackt, zeige euch das mal ein bisschen, guck, Alter,
wie viel Belagerungszeug haben die dann bitte aufgestellt, ne das sind noch die alten, übrigens
hier Physix, DAOG Physix live, so funktioniert das auch immer, so haben die das im Mittelalter
auch gemacht mit ihren Belagerungswaffen, so ich glaube die versuchen ein Loch in die
Festung zu schießen, ah das Loch ist ja schon da, dann versuchen sie wahrscheinlich die
Gegner drinnen zu unterbrechen, also du kannst in diese Festung nicht nur das Tor aufrahmen,
du kannst auch Löcher in die Seite machen, um dann da rein zu Chargen, wir haben das
gerade probiert mit dem rein Chargen, das hat nicht so gut funktioniert, guck mal, die
Gegner müssen im Prinzip einfach nur A.E. auf das Loch hier hauen, beziehungsweise auf
jemand der in der Öffnung steht und man kommt nicht richtig durch, also da rein Chargen
ist schon ein bisschen, bisschen lebensmüde gerade, dafür gibt das massig Punkte, sollten
wir das Keep einnehmen und sogar erobern, die 20 FPS kommen im Stream nicht so rüber,
ist es im Stream ja wahrscheinlich läuft es im Stream besser, ich merke das aber sofort
am Maus Movement und allem, dass es eben einfach nur richtig wie es läuft, ja und ansonsten
ich kann euch ein bisschen was, ich kann euch ein bisschen was erzählen noch zu den, zu
den Spells und sowas, ja die Zauberleiste ist oben, also die Leiste ist oben links sind
sogar drei Leisten, ich gehe jetzt mal hier vor, falls er da gleich rein Chargen will,
hier drinnen sieht man übrigen die Gegner stehen, was sie überm Kopf haben sind ihre
jeweiligen Ränge, dass man sieht ob die Noobs sind oder, was heißt Noobs, ob man sieht ob
die 24-7 spielen oder nicht, ich weiß nicht so genau was die ja gerade vorhaben, alter
ich werde einfach noch zerstört gerade von den gegnerischen Castern, ich weiß nicht
ob das so eine gute Idee ist hier jetzt darum zu pimmeln, aber gut ich bleibe jetzt mal
hier stehen, ich gehe da bestimmt nicht rein, übrigens man kann auch seinen Character hier
ordentlich beleuchten, dann sieht man ein bisschen mehr, ich lasse es jetzt mal an,
dass ihr vielleicht ein bisschen was seht, oh Gegner, Bashen, Down, alter der erste Nächste
hat schon wieder LD, die Rechner brennen durch von den Leuten, zu viel, zu viel los, also
wir sind 160, ich würde sagen da drinnen sind ungefähr noch mal 160 Gegner, da ist
eigentlich, ist das Pils, das ist Pils da hinten, guck mal da, das ist so der Battle
Group Anführer von den anderen, bei uns ist es Polemo und bei denen ist es Pils, ja und
zu den Spells, ich spiele eine Klasse die gar nicht so viele Fähigkeiten hat und ich
komme schon mit drei Leisten und Zusatz-Switch-Leisten nicht richtig aus und ich nutze auch bei
Weitem nicht alles, ja ich nutze für meine Waffe genau einen Angriff, ok zwei, zwei Angriffe,
das war's.
Wenn man jetzt mal einen ordentlichen Fight hätte, ob ein Field-Toma was sehen würde,
könnte ich euch auch ein bisschen was zeigen, ich habe zwei DDs, also Damage, einfach instant
draufklicken und Taste drücken, kriegt Gegner, bekommt Damage, ich habe Nahkampf-Angriff,
kann ich mit meinem Schwert draufhauen, dann habe ich Damage Song, Speed Song, also sprich
dass die Gruppe schneller läuft, dass die Gruppe mehr Damage macht, Gegner verlangsamen,
Gegner betäuben, dass wir ein bisschen mehr aushallen, dass wir uns heilen, dass wir weniger
Ausdauer verbrauchen, Mana für die Gruppe und ein paar andere Sachen, dann habe ich
auch ein paar Tränke, Mana-Trunk, Speed-Trunk, Endo-Trunk, noch ein paar Resis, falls einer
auf uns kaste, dass wir mehr aushalten, dass wir unter Wasser atmen können, da habe ich
einen Buff, oh das war's, also Skalde hat nicht all zu viele Fähigkeiten, wenn man zum Beispiel
Heiler spielt oder gar Hexe oder sowas, dann reichen drei, letztes wo ich gestreamt habe
ich glaube ich Sork gespielt, also Hexe, da habe ich wirklich fünf Leisten voll gehabt,
die Leute sterben wieder, wollen die da wirklich reinpushen jetzt, seriously, oh komm mal jetzt
den Alps am Start auch noch, XP weg, oh da kann man ein bisschen Damage drauf machen,
aber ich habe auch keine Ahnung, was hier gerade abgeht, unsere Leute pimmeln irgendwie
in der Festung rum, ah guck mal da unten sind sie, nice, ich guck mal ob ich da jetzt auch
durchkomme, da jetzt auch durch, wo sind die Gegner, ich drücke jetzt einfach mal scheiß
drauf, ich habe keine Ahnung, ich gehe jetzt mal rein in die Festung, ok GG Eats, wo ist
dann eigentlich unser Anführer hin, ist der hier oben, ok, ich habe keine Ahnung, ich
muss Effekte ausmachen, ich blicke nicht mehr durch, ist mir zu viel, ok hier oben stehen
einige rum, da stehen ganz viele Tote rum, da sind die Gegner, das können wir im Leben
doch nicht einnehmen hier, wie soll das funktionieren, wie soll das funktionieren, wo liegen eigentlich
unsere Leute tot rum, ach da hinten, super, da können wir jetzt auch nicht wiederbeleben
jetzt, ja das läuft ja exzellent, brauchen unsere Heiler Mana, ok ich weiß nicht so genau
was der Plan hier ist ehrlich gesagt, außer sich vor den Gegnern zu verstecken, tja dann
stehen wir mal hier unten rum und hoffen, dass wir nicht gekillt werden, die Gegner
haben sich in der Mitte verschanzt, jetzt pushen auch noch ein paar Alps, ok nice, also ihr
seht es hier drinnen, guck mal im Keep selbst, das da, das sind die, die zu diesem grünen
reich gehören und jetzt sind auch noch welche, die zu dem roten reich gehören reingepusht
und das ist der Grund, warum es das beste PvP Game ever ist, weil nur, damage machen,
weil nur so ist nicht, kann nie eine Partei viel zu, viel zu krass OP sein, krillst du
auch in der Arbeitspause, mittags, nee eigentlich nicht, weil immer wenn eine Partei, also wenn
ein reich zu stark ist, können die anderen zwei rein, kann quasi, wenn die feiten, kann
das dritte noch reinpushen, deswegen ist es einfach best game ever, oh die sehen jetzt
nicht so nett aus da hinten, ich sollte mich mal verpissen, oh guck mal ein Gegner, der
gerade einloggt, der ist noch immun vom einloggen, lull, wir hauen den oben sobald die immun
sind, oh nee, oh nee, er ist rausgeflogen, fuck, also ich glaube wir sollten uns hier
wieder verpissen ehrlich gesagt, weil einnehmen können wir das keep mit so vielen leuten drin
und auch im leben nicht, guck mal da, hier hinten sind irgendwie 100, 100 Gegner, unten
sind 100 Gegner, wir sind zwar 160, aber wie sollen wir das einnehmen, ich mach mich schon
mal bereit runterzuspringen, falls jetzt hier irgendwie was pusht, guckst du dir an da hinten,
ich geh jetzt auch wieder runter, das ist mir nichts, ok unsere Verstärkung ist auf
dem weg, ihr sehts auf der map, die Verstärkung kommt, deswegen ist bei sowas unglaublich
wichtig, dass man hier hinporten kann, weil wir können hinporten, die Gegner nicht, also
heißt wenn das hier ne weile geht, haben wir die besseren chancen, das tor müsste auch
gleich auf sein, ich guck noch mal was das tor macht, ist das tor offen, ist das tor
offen, oh das könnte doch was werden leute, ist das tor offen, ich sehs nicht, tor ist
5% ok, ok, wir müssen eigentlich nur einmal an das tor pushen dann ist es offen, das könnte
doch was werden, postchamp, das könnte, also wir könnten das, also wenn das tor aufgeht
wir könnten das tatsächlich einnehmen, wir müssen uns dann natürlich irgendwie die durch
100 gegner schnetzeln, dass wir zum boss kommen und den killen können, aber jo, das könnte
tatsächlich was werden, hier ist die french connection am start, ja mach damage, mach
damage auf das tor, so unsere Verstärkung ist auch wieder da, leute das könnte was
werden, das könnte was werden, guck mal es kommen immer mehr, es kommen immer mehr, wo
sind eigentlich unsere leute gerade, wo sind eigentlich meine teammates gerade, alle, da
ist einer, da steht er und macht nix, was soll er auch machen, ah, großer anführer,
was sollen wir denn machen, auf damage aufs tor oder was sollen wir machen?
ich gette die tactic noch nicht ganz, also ich meine 5% damage am tor, ok, wir wollen
irgendwas machen, ok, ich laufe ihm einfach mal hinterher, ich laufe ihm einfach mal hinterher,
wo ist er hin, da oben, da oben ist er, der bot hat eine stunde verspätung gehabt, nice,
toll, oh, gegner bashen, ja, oh die pushen rein, da muss man jetzt aufpassen, also wenn
jetzt alle ein bisschen nach rechts gehen, können wir die easy wegklatschen, also caster
können nur auf dich damage machen, wenn sie dich sehen können, deswegen, ne ne ne, da
gehe ich nicht rein, das könnt ihr vergessen, da pushe ich nicht rein in 300 gegner, ganz
bestimmt nicht, keep gate 4, ok, 4% das tor, hoffen wir kriegen das noch gebacken jetzt
und es stirbt keiner bis das tor auf ist, ich muss mal grad die musik neu starten, ah
windows 11, please, da hinten sterben grad alle, warum pushen die da auch hin, die sind
so bescheuert, warum, warum, jetzt mal seriously, warum pusht man als nahkämpfer in 30 gegner
rein, also ich mein was soll denn da bitteschön schon bei rauskommen außer das man stirbt,
oh der große meister ist gerade runter gesprungen, wenn der das macht mache ich das auch, oder
auch nicht, ok ich hab keine ahnung was wir hier genau vorhaben, hauen wir mal ne wache
um, was willst du machen, super jetzt stehe ich, über 8 sekunden, du könntest den twitch
beinahe um das archiv machen, das ist ne gute idee, ok leute ich hab echt keine ahnung,
jetzt pushen sie raus, gut nice, ich hab keine ahnung, leave, ok jetzt sollen wir abhauen,
das hat sich jetzt nicht so wirklich gelohnt, ich guck mal ob ich noch ein paar leute mit
nehmen kann von uns, nein keine chance, sind alle tot am keep, ok keine ahnung leute, irgendwie
geht jetzt heute doch nicht so viel außer irgendwie komische festungsbelagerungen wo
gerade doch nicht so viel geht, ich hol euch mal ab, von unserer gruppe ist aktuell keiner
da, also guck mal meine nameplates sind kaputt, muss ich grad mal fixen, ich hoffe das macht
es wieder ganz, ja nice, ok leute ich hol mal meine teammates, können wir vielleicht
ein paar gegner killen zur abwechslung, guck mal da, gegner, bam, next, hey wir sehen mal
ein paar in person gegner, wahnsinn, nicht nur durch irgendwelche fensteröffnungen im
keep, ja ja wir standen alle nur rum, deswegen hab ich auch den sinn von diesem angriff da
drauf, das keep nicht gecheckt, guck mal noch ein paar gegner, oh ich hab die effekte aus,
deswegen, ich wundere mich schon warum ich keine casteffekte sehe, alter wir sind verdammt
viele leute, aber ich weiß trotzdem nicht ob es so die beste sache ist hier den keep
rate zu machen, aber was man jetzt schon sieht ist, dass es sich taktisch gelohnt hat dass
wir die festung geholt haben, weil wir jetzt relativ easy nachschub haben, tja was kann
ich euch ansonsten über das game erzählen, was kann ich euch ansonsten über das game
erzählen, es gibt für alle pve fans oder für alle pvm fans gibt es ein bisschen was
zu tun aber es ist eigentlich kein spiel für leute die wahnsinnig gerne pve machen, ja
es gibt ein paar endgame raids, es gibt beispielsweise einen endgame dungeon zum farmen und tja aber
ansonsten also die ganzen pve lovers werden wahrscheinlich nicht so glücklich werden mit
dauer, dafür ist es halt im pvp das beste game, auch wenn man heute außer festungsbelagerung
nicht so viel gesehen hat, aber vielleicht gibt es jetzt noch ein paar open field fights,
ich werde übrigens auch nicht mal allzu lange spielen, denke mal noch so eine viertel stunde
oder so, mal gucken, ich werde das die tage nochmal streamen, weil ich spiele eh jeden
tag, ich werde das die tage nochmal streamen und dann warte ich vorher mal wie sich so
entwickelt, wir hatten ein paar richtig gute fights bevor ich den stream angemacht hab,
ich hab mir gedacht nice, jetzt kannst du den leuten noch mal ne stunde ein bisschen
was zeigen, aber das nächste mal spiele ich mal eins, eineinhalb stunden und guck wie
so der fluss ist an diesem abend bevor ich anmache, weil rein keep defense oder keep
attack ist auch nicht so spannend, also zumindest was man jetzt gesehen hat ist, oh guck mal
vielleicht erwischen wir die, eigentlich sollten wir die nicht erwischen, was man schon gesehen
hat ist, es waren alle drei reiche oben an dem keep, es waren alps, es waren hips und
es waren jedes mal richtig viele, jawoll gib ihn, gib ihn, endlich mal ein ordentlicher
fight, auf auf jungs, drauf, oh ich muss die effekte ausmachen, fuck, so und jetzt muss
man aufpassen, dass man nicht zu sehr in die gegner pusht, wenn ich zu tief reinpushe in
die gegner bin ich instant down, das machen auch viele, die neu mit dem game anfangen,
die pushen einfach viel zu extrem, du musst pushen wenn du momentum hast und wenn du keins
hast musst du erstmal gucken wo du am besten hingehst, so und jetzt wieder hinter, bevor
mich einer groß umballert, nach süden sollen wir, ok nach süden, alles klar, also hierhin,
mach ich, da sind sie, würde ich sagen, endlich mal ein gescheiter fight, haben ganz schön
aufs maul gekriegt, wenn ich überbrücke pushe kriege ich bestimmt anches vom großen, vom
großen meister, und der flippt teilweise im discord, ich sag es euch, der flippt teilweise
richtig aus, einziger darkstream, ok, der flippt teilweise richtig aus, ist mega lustig,
polemow ist der einzige, wirklich der hauptgrund warum ich dieses spiel in diesem realm auf
spiele, ich finde den kerl mega unterhaltsam, und da macht das auch wirklich gut, also der
hat die battlegroup im griff und wenn er ausrastet, kannst du dich immer wegschmeißen, das ist
ein grieche, ich glaube der ist 60 oder so, ist ein bisschen älter, ist ein grieche
und flucht immer auf griechisch rum, wenn die leute es nicht richtig machen, oh wie viele
gegner, bashen, gib ihm, bloß nicht reinpushen, bloß nicht reinpushen, guck jetzt siehst
ihr, da sind jetzt wieder jede menge die nicht aufpassen, guck guck, es pushen jetzt wieder
welche zum keep und sterben, warum, weil sie das game nicht verstanden haben, wie so ein
bisschen der fluss von den fights ist, du kannst mal sowas, guck guck jetzt sterben sie schon
wieder, alter leute, hier der ist dead, guck guck, die checken sie überhaupt nicht, so
schlimm, oh nee routet, ich mein es ist doch klar, jetzt mal, ich komm ja ungern mit realismus
vergleichen ja, aber wenn du an irgendeine festung pusht und davor ein paar gekillt hast,
da wirst du doch nicht wenn verteidiger auf den zinnen stehen sagen, ach ja ich lauf
jetzt mal bis an die mauern und lass mir das heiße wasser und sonst was auf den kopf schütten,
die leute sind teilweise richtig blöde was sowas angeht, man muss in dem spiel wissen
wann man pushen kann, wann man pushen kann und wann nicht, guck mal ein paar gegner,
jetzt bräuchte man das weiße high theme, können wir effekt auch wieder anmachen, wasser fights
sind immer so ein ding, guck mal hier das halbe, halbe group ist wieder verreckt und
wir sind jetzt auf dem weg hier hin zurück, jetzt verrecken sie da hinten wieder, ich
hoffe wir gehen unsere leute abholen jetzt und sonst wird das nix, deswegen hab ich ungern
komplett unbekannte leute in group, da weißt du immer nicht ob die so die basics da drauf
haben oder nicht, guck mal wo sie rumgammeln da hinten, die können nicht weiter weil da
wahrscheinlich gegner dazwischen sind, die einfach nicht sterben sollen am keep, ja wenn
ihr wollt, also wenn wir fertig sind mit bg, ich kann euch noch mal ein bisschen sowas
über das game zeigen und die klassen und sowas, ach guck mal das ist ein gegner, aha
erwischt, ich hoffe unsere leute charging da jetzt hinterher, weil ich hab mal aus dem
speed gehauen, der sollte jetzt eigentlich nicht wegkommen, alter volle pulle hinterher,
ja gib ihm, auf auf, bam, next, an dem hab ich aber ganz schön damage gedrückt gerade,
normalerweise brauch ich nicht nur 2 hits für so einen, schon wieder eine ld, ja ich bin
immer noch überrascht, wie viele rechner, also bei den spielern die das 2023 spielen,
wie viele rechner immer noch überfordert sind von dem game, guckt euch mal diesen riesen
zerk an der hier gerade lang pusht, wie viele rechner immer noch von dem game überfordert
sind und irgendwelche connection probleme haben oder ruckeln oder eben gleich komplett
rausfliegen oder pushen welche nice, oh ich muss runter, ich muss runter, ich muss weg
weg weg weg weg, das ist mir da oben auf jeden fall zu heiß, jetzt wird gepusht, gib ihm,
aber nicht ans keep pushen leute, nein die wache will ich nicht anhauen, ok wieder weg,
jetzt sterben sie wieder, ist polemu ein deutscher, nee polemu ist grieche, was man auch wenn
man mit dem discord mit ihm ist, merkt wenn er anfängt die leute auf einmal wüsthoff
griechisch zu beleidigen, ich hab ein paar griechische schimpfwörter durch ihn gelernt,
ich glaube das eine heißt so viel wie ich ficke deine mutter, ich sag es jetzt aber
nicht im stream, weil ich keine ahnung habe was es genau heißt und ich ungern sachen sage
von denen ich nicht weiß was sie bedeuten, ich glaube es heißt so viel wie ich ficke
deine mutter auf griechisch, also die wichtigen sachen habe ich schon mal gelernt von ihm,
pushen wir, oh nee jawoll ich bin noch rausgekommen mit speed, jetzt lassen sich die gegner ordentlich
farmen, ok effekte wieder aus, jetzt kann ich übrigens jedem nur empfehlen macht euch
ein makro effekte an effekte aus, weil wenn es hoch her geht versteht ihr in diesem spiel
nichts, solange effekte an sind und selbst wenn effekte aus sind ist es manchmal undurchsichtig
was da so passiert, ok nix wie weg, die leute sterben schon wieder, wie schaffen die das
die ganze zeit, was macht ihr denn dahinten, so ich hole mal unseren achter ab, in der hoffnung
ah da ist sie, in der hoffnung die anderen schaffen es auch noch mal irgendwann her,
ja also wenn wir mit pk fertig sind, wenn die leute ins bett müssen, wie gesagt wir spielen
normalerweise auch nur bis 22 uhr, dann zeige ich euch noch ein bisschen was zu dem game,
zeige euch noch die klassen, die spielwelt und sowas, dass ihr ein bisschen was gesehen
habt, weil ich könnte mir vorstellen, das könnt ihr mir mal in chat schreiben, ich
kanns mir eigentlich denken, aber ihr könnts mir mal in chat schreiben, also in 5 minuten
dann in chat, wenn ihr das spiel noch nie gespielt habt, also erstens wird mich interessieren
welche leute haben wir am start dieses spiel vielleicht noch von früher kennen und wenn
ihr das spiel noch nie gesehen habt, man checkt nix oder, der eichler dankeschön für den
sub, ach guck mal, was ist denn hier, wo kommst denn du her, wo kommst denn du her, dad, man
checkt nix oder, also wenn man das spiel nicht kennt, man ist absolut überfordert, man denkt
sich, alter warum rennen die da die ganze zeit rum und drücken irgendwelche knöpfe und
lupen so oft im kreis und was machen die da eigentlich, ich glaube wirklich, wenn man
das spiel nicht kennt, checkt man erstmal gar nix, deswegen ist es vielleicht nicht
die beste idee gewesen euch jetzt direkt in battlegroup pvp zu werfen, aber ist halt das
was heute abend angestanden hat, was soll ich machen, ey, stirbt der jetzt wieder, vielleicht
können wir unsere sieben noch safen hier, ja, noch ein paar einzelne gegner, gut die
können nix machen, was sollen die machen gegen 160 leute, der weiße high ist unterwegs
ja, es gibt übrigens nen riesen high, also bevor es in battlefield ein mega, wie spricht
man das ding aus, megalodon, megalodon, wie auch immer, bevor es den in battlefield 4
gab, gab es in dark auch schon einen, es gibt, hier hat man die drei grenzgebiete, da hat
man noch ne insel in der mitte und das meer quasi zwischen diesen drei grenzgebieten,
da schwimmt so ein riesen high rum, den kann man auch killen und der droppt ganz gute Sachen,
man läuft im baum, neue tasks, jupp, aber das macht, das macht er hier wahrscheinlich
neue tasks holen, ja, ich kann euch jetzt mal zeigen, also der vorteil ist wirklich,
wenn man jetzt nen keep hier hat, man kann jetzt, ich glaub wir laufen, laufen wir schon
wieder los, ne, ok, wir sollen sticken, ich mach mal was der meister sagt, ist glaub ich
besser für alle, ne, jetzt ist er weg, ok, jetzt können wir new tasks tatsächlich holen,
also jetzt sieht man, dass das wirklich ein vorteil ist, wenn man nen keep geholt
hat mit unterschiedlichen türmen, weil ich kann jetzt bei uns zurück porten zu unserem
außen posten und kann neue quests und alles mögliche holen und dann kann ich direkt wieder
zurück in die action porten, also sehr praktisch, wenn man da nen keep hat, so mal schauen was
wir jetzt machen, auch mal wieder effekte an, das spiel ist nicht sonderlich sparsam
mit effekten, ja also, ihr habt es ja eben im fight gesehen, also wenn da ae damage gecastet
wird oder die heiler heilen, das blinkt und blitzt und explodiert an allen stellen, ihr
sehts ja auch hier die buff effekte und sowas, deswegen muss ich, wenn fights sind, wo wirklich
mehrere oder viele, also irgendwie 50, 50, 100, 100, was auch immer, da musst du die
effekte ausschalten, man braucht eigentlich nen makro für effekte aus, also ich spiel
manchmal den halben abend ohne effekte, einfach weil sonst zu viel abgeht, glaub die nächsten
tage fang ich mal ein bisschen früher an, bg ging heute leider erst ein bisschen später
los, guck mal die leute haben sie wieder nicht gecheckt, dass wir loslaufen, was hier passiert,
schwer zu erklären, ok mal gucken was wir jetzt vorhaben, mal gespannt, ich vermute
mal, ich vermute mal wir werden noch ein paar hürmer hier drum herum einnehmen, eventuell
das nächste keep, man weiß es nicht, mal schauen, ich bin zumindest froh, dass wir
nicht mehr an dc sind, dc weil ich eben wirklich ziemliches auf den sack bekomme, ja und eine
andere sache muss ich euch auch noch erzählen, weil das was ist was ich bei vielen moderneren
mmos vermisse, bei modernen mmos die verfolgen ja so die philosophie, jeder kann alles machen,
also jeder soll solo bis ins endgame kommen können zur not, jeder soll solo leveln können
und jede klasse muss quasi alle quests alleine schaffen außer vielleicht die absoluten endgame,
endgame quests und solche geschichten und da muss ich sagen, es ist vielleicht tatsächlich
eine entwicklung die notwendig ist für die massentauglichkeit eines mmos, also ich verstehe
das warum das spielehersteller machen, aber ich muss sagen ich finde es für mmos trotzdem
nicht schön, ich finde es besser wenn du in mmos tatsächlich so eine rollenverteilung
hast, dass du leute die gerne support spielen auch support spielen lässt und nicht irgendwie
zwangsläufig du musst jetzt support spielen indem du damage machst und es gibt ja spiele
so nach dem motto der support macht halt damage aber heilt dann die gruppe durch damage und
sowas in der richtung, also in dark ist die rollenverteilung doch relativ oldschool, ich
meine das spiel ist von 2002, also du hast in dark zum beispiel supporter, du hast auch
so ein paar so hybrid supporter und sonst was, aber du hast durchaus so hard support könnte
man da sagen, würde man vielleicht in der moba welt, würde man vielleicht hard support
sagen und zwar du hast hier beispielsweise 2 hiler in der gruppe und ein shami und hiler
ist der beste also kann man sich jetzt sicherlich drüber streiten aber meiner meinung nach
ist hiler die beste support klasse im gesamten spiel, ein paar gegner sind in den turm rein
who cares, sind 3 stück da, guck mal da rennt noch einer, dead, noch mehr, gib ihm, oh wir
dürfen nicht chasen, wenn wir chasen kriegen wir vom polem und anschüss, nein wir sollen
sticken ok, wir sticken, ja also wie gesagt und hiler ist finde ich die beste support
klasse, die beste support klasse im ganzen spiel, die anderen sind auch nicht schlecht
aber ich finde hiler ist universell einfach die beste klasse, die es gibt, die kann heilen,
die kann buffen, die kann cc, die kann alles, also hiler ist wenn nicht die beste klasse
im spiel, also mit einer der besten support, also die beste support klasse, wenn nicht
einer der besten klasse im gesamten spiel und als hiler kannst du halt selbst keinen
damage machen und das ist was, was es in modernen mmos so nicht geben würde, in modernen mmos
könnten hiler zumindest alle content solo machen, hier kannst du als hiler im endeffekt
nichts solo machen, du killst nichts, du machst keinen damage, ich meine du kannst ein bisschen
damage machen, wenn du dir eine waffe mit brock besorgst und alles auf die eine linie
speckst, die ein bisschen, aber eigentlich macht das keiner, diese buff und die buff
leiste macht mich fertig, warum, ist halt relativ viel was da abgeht, haha, gegner und wie gesagt
in modernen mmos wäre das so, der hiler müsste selbst genug damage machen, müsste selbst
alle quests machen, ist ja nicht, du kriegst als hiler hier schlicht und ergreifend gar
nichts auf die reihe solo, was aber ok ist, dafür bist du die beste support klasse im
ganzen spiel, du kannst heilen, so gut wie alle anderen, so main, main, hiler, du kannst
alles c10 was du willst, du hast speed, du hast instant cc, du hast alles, du killst
halt nur nichts, so ein hiler kann quasi alles, nur nicht damage machen und das finde ich
viel cooler als so die moderne mmo philosophie, jeder muss auch alles solo hinkriegen, du
hast in da auch genug klassen die solo spielen können, also ich würde sagen das was ich
hier spiele, btf, was, wo ist er hin, das was ich hier spiele ist eigentlich so mit eines
der besten solo klassen, man hat speed, man kann mitrennen, man macht relativ gut einmalig
burst damage, aber es gibt halt auch richtig harte support klassen, also die können alleine
nichts killen aber sind unglaublich gut, halt in allem außer damage machen, guck mal, warum
haben die sich aus dem turm getraut, sind die blöd, null, kriegen sie auf den sack weil
sie sich aus dem turm getraut haben, next, bam, oh, na nicht so sehr reinpushen, da nicht
so sehr reinpushen, boah sind wir viele mitz, alter guck mal, boah sind wir viele mitz,
guck mal hier, alles voll, das sind, moment, bg count, 193 Leute, the fuck, 193 Leute, ich
glaube so viele habe ich noch nie gesehen in einer bg, ok die sind nicht alle hier,
man muss sagen viele leechen auch einfach nur infos aus der bg, also die gehen dann
in die bg, gucken sich den chat an, den ihr gerade nicht seht, gucken sich den chat an,
sehen dann wo was abgeht aber sind selbst nicht in der bg dabei, aber 193 Leute, das
ist ja krass, also so viel ist es normalerweise nicht, normalerweise ist das so 70 oder so,
also wir sind quasi doppelt bis dreimal so viel wie sonst, also das ist schon heftig,
vielleicht hat er mal ein stream ein bisschen, wäre natürlich cool, wenn manche Leute jetzt
gesagt hätten, hey wir wollen rennen mit, weil es gerade auf twitch, aber ich glaube
es nicht, wir haben 123 Leute gerade, das ist ja, ich meine wir haben quasi mehr in der
bg als twitch, das sind alles echte Spieler, das sind alles echte Spieler was ihr hier
seht alex, kann ich vielleicht auch nochmal betonen, das sind alles echte Spieler, alles
echte Spieler, die haben zwar gestickt hier an unserem Leader, das sind alles echte Spieler,
alles echte Spieler, alles echte Spieler, ich frag mich jetzt gerade nur was wir vorhaben,
die Gegner sind wieder raus gepusht, alter sind die blöde teilweise, Gegner werden vernichtet,
pushen wieder raus und werden gleich wieder vernichtet, Achtung, Achtung, da sind sie,
da sind sie schon, jetzt haben sie es gemerkt, jetzt haben sie festgestellt, oh Mist, da
kommen ja 190 Mits, ihnen gerade entgegen gerannt, nix wie weg, deswegen nennt man sowas
in diesem Spiel einen Zerg, ich glaube bessere, bessere Umschreibung gibt es dafür gar nicht,
weggezerkt, jetzt sind natürlich noch ein paar in dieses Labyrinth geflüchtet, müssen
wir mal kurz suchen, naja oder auch nicht, aber die Gegner, also manchmal, manchmal verstehe
ich die, also uns auch nicht, ja, also manchmal verstehe ich nicht was die Spieler so machen,
du wirst gekillt, Chancenlos, so, was machst du, du gehst wieder hin und dann machen die
Gegner exakt das gleiche, was dich das letzte Mal gekillt hat und du denkst dir dann so,
ja gut, dann laufe ich denen einfach mal wieder hinterher, wirst wieder gekillt, ok, zweimal
reingefallen, dann portest du wieder hin und denkst dir so, ach komm wir gehen mal aus
dem Turm, wir rennen mal den Gegnern hinterher und wirst wieder gekillt und das machst du
den ganzen Abend oder was, also manchmal verstehe ich die Leute nicht, manchmal leuchtet es
mir echt nicht ein was da abgeht, aus irgendwelchen Gründen ist es Manschami, ah Manschami steht
da hinten irgendwo rum und ja gut, Detge, müssen wir mal kurz umschalten, ah hier so,
wo ist der große Meister, da vorne, Westen Regroup, ok, wir regroupen, aber jetzt haben
wir wenigstens mal ein paar Fights, wenn auch keine richtig krassen Übergross, ihr Battle,
ihr Massen Epic Battles, sondern noch ein bisschen kleinere, aber immerhin sieht man
mal ein bisschen was, guck jetzt pushen sie wieder raus, jetzt pushen wir gleich wieder
gegen und sie sterben wieder, dann frage ich mich so, lernen die es einfach nicht, oh jetzt
wollten sie High IQ Flank machen Leute, High IQ Flank mit einer Kuppe von der Seite, jawoll,
ihr seht übrigens ja manchmal, dass ich schneller laufe und manchmal langsamer, das liegt daran,
Speed hat man nur solange man keinen Damage bekommt und keinen Damage macht, wäre ja auch
ein bisschen unfair, wenn ich die ganze Zeit hier da rumflitzen könnte, das ist einer
von uns, normalerweise macht man übrigens das Licht nachts aus, früher hast du gesagt
Licht an gleich Noob, aber ich habe das Licht für euch an, dass man was sieht, oh Gott,
das habe ich allen ernstes, ich bin ja an diesem Drecks Viech hängen geblieben, es sieht nicht
aus wie wow, das hat überhaupt keinen Comic Grafik Stil, es hat aber und ich glaube da können
wir insofern ganz froh darüber sein, dass Starhawk 2002 rausgekommen ist, es hat einen wie ich finde
relativ zeitlosen, nicht so zeitlos wie Pixel Grafik, aber einen relativ zeitlosen Grafik Stil,
es ist noch aus der Zeit, wo man es nicht versucht hat möglichst realistisch zu machen, man hat es
zwar realistisch angehockt, aber nicht so ultra realistisch, so wie geht es zur aktuellen Zeit,
so dass es nach fünf Jahren an Kacke aussieht, wenn sich die Technik weiter, was machen die Alps
hier drinnen, die Technik weiterentwickelt hat, es hat einen relativ zeitlosen Grafik Stil für
den MMO, guck mal hier, geil, hier war ich auch noch nie drin, nice Hütte, aber die Gegner checken
es nicht oder, wir haben die jetzt schon fünf mal gekillt und die sind immer noch der Meinung,
ja ja es ist eine gute Idee da wieder entgegen zu laufen, wenn die weglaufen, ja ja ganz ganz
ganz schlau, eigentlich wollte ich schon längst aufhören, aber solange meine Leute nicht aufhören,
bleibe ich auch noch, bleibe ich auch noch dabei, vielleicht machen wir, vielleicht läuft es
sogar bis auf den Relic Trade oder so raus, mal gucken, weil es ist so, glaube ich aber nicht,
sind viel zu viele Gegner da für den Relic Trade, es ist so, wenn man PvP macht, es gibt nicht nur
diese, die ich euch gezeigt habe, so PvP Punkte, ja diese Ränge, es gibt auch slash Relic oder nee
slash, ja das geht auch, slash, slash Relic ist glaube ich das bessere, nee das ist übersicht,
slash Relic war schon richtig, jedes Reich hat auch, hat auch, das UI teilweise, jedes Reich
hat auch zwei Relikte und man sieht hier gerade, dass wir keine Relikte mehr haben,
ein Info Relic kann man machen, also jedes, jedes Reich hat zwei Relikte, die Alps haben hier
Excalibur und Merlins Stab und die Mütze haben Thors Hammer und, ach keine Ahnung, ich weiß
gar nicht, ich wie gesagt, Geschichte, Lore, kenne ich nicht, zumindest hat jedes Reich ein
Magier Relikt und ein Nahkampf Relikt und wenn du das Relikt des gegnerischen Reiches erobert hast,
kriegst du 10% mehr Nahkampf Damage oder 10% mehr Magieschaden oder aber beides, wenn du beide hast
und wenn du gar alle hast, hast du 20% mehr Damage auf alles, also das ist gar nicht mal so sehr zu
vernachlässigen, 20% Damage ist ordentlich, ich bin mir aber nicht sicher, ob es auf jeden auch so
ist, es könnte sein, dass sie das im Free Shot ein bisschen angepasst haben, dass die Relikte nicht
mehr so viel Bonus bringen, ich glaube die Relikte bringen hier ein bisschen gar keinen oder weniger,
ich glaube weniger Bonus, wir kloppen jetzt erstmal die Tür auf, das ist so quasi so das Endgame
im PvP, Gegner killen, Festung einnehmen und gegnerische Relikte erobern, das ist aber nicht
so einfach die Relikte zu erobern, weil ihr seht ja hier die Karte vom Grenzgebiet, also von diesem
einen von drei Grenzgebieten und das Relikt liegt hier und dieses Relikt liegt hinter zwei
Toren, also hinter so einem Tor, was man hoch und runter fahren kann, ich habe keine Ahnung
wie der richtige Begriff ist, das ist hinter zwei Toren und man muss, damit diese Tore aufgehen,
damit diese Toren aufgehen, muss man quasi den Großteil des gegnerischen Gebietes erobern,
inklusive einer der Festungen, die direkt an der Grenze liegen, das ist gar nicht so einfach und
erst wenn man das geschafft hat, dann gehen hier die Defenses runter, die Mauern gehen auf und man
kann in den Relikt Tempel das Relikt holen und dann muss man zurück, muss durch das komplette
Grenzgebiet zurücklaufen oder mit dem Schiff schwimmen oder durch den RVR Dungeon gehen,
zurück und entweder legt man es hier ab in einem der Keeps oder wenn es das eigene Relikt ist bei
sich im Relikt Tempel, also das ist eine Sache, das ist meistens so eine Kampagne quasi von
drei, vier Stunden oder länger, also das ist oftmals oder geht auch manchmal über Tage, das ist
oftmals ein bisschen aufwändiger Relikt zu erobern. Wie viele FPS hast du jetzt? Ich weiß nicht,
wahrscheinlich irgendwie 70, 80, jetzt geht es gerade ganz gut. Mal gucken, was wir jetzt
als nächstes machen, aber man muss auch sagen, also die große Taktik ist es jetzt nicht,
ja, also auch wenn ich jetzt erzähle, dass da schon ein bisschen mehr Tiefe dabei ist und so,
das Spiel ist relativ taktisch, wenn man es mit kleinen Anzahl an Leuten spielt, also wenn man
beispielsweise in Achtergruppe spielt oder gar noch weniger, wenn man eins bis vier Spieler spielt,
dann ist das Spiel tatsächlich relativ taktisch, jetzt nicht taktisch in Form von wie die Taktik
in CSGO, sondern es ist hauptsächlich, wie nennt man das so schön, Decision Making, also du musst
halt relativ schnell einschätzen können, ok, was hat der Gegner für Klassen, was können die
gegnerischen Klassen machen, was ist von meinen Fähigkeiten gut dagegen und nachdem es relativ
viele Klassen gibt, wie gesagt, es gibt drei Reiche, jedes Reich hat um die 13 Klassen glaube ich,
gibt es da relativ vieles, also man muss ein bisschen so knowledge aufbauen in dem Game,
dass man eben auch mit weniger Leuten gut spielen kann, aber die meisten spielen das Game halt schon
verdammt lang, aber es ist immer noch unglaublich, wie gesagt, das hier was wir jetzt hier machen ist
nicht die hohe Kunst, früher hätte ich mich da lustig drüber gemacht, hätte ich gesagt, ha guckt
euch mal die Zerga an, ja können sie nix, ist irgendwo auch so, aber ich muss sagen, mir macht
in letzter Zeit BG RVR deutlich mehr Bock, vor allem weil man einfach reinjoinen kann, geht in
eine BG und kloppt sich ein bisschen mit den Gegnern, zum Beispiel den da vorne, der jetzt
alleine in 180 Leute reingerannt ist, Pepega Style, aber wie gesagt, das ist jetzt in diesem großen
Umfang hier, also Battle Group vs. Battle Groups ist jetzt keine Wahnsinns Taktik, aber man sollte
das auch nicht unterschätzen, also man kann, auch wenn das nicht so aussieht, man kann als einzelne
Gruppe und teilweise je nach Klasse auch als einzelne Spieler hier teilweise Fights entscheiden,
also bei großen Fights ist es hauptsächlich erstmal eine Frage, wie gut ist der Anführer,
also sprich, wie gut wird da engaged, also sprich pusht man schräg von der Seite in die Gegner
rein, hat man die bessere Position, müssen die Gegner beispielsweise den Berg hier hoch pushen,
dann hätten wir die instant, instant würden wir die bashen, wenn die den Berg hochkommen,
weil wir können auf sie casten, sie können nicht von unten gescheit rauf casten und sowas,
aber man kann auch als einzelne Gruppe oder auch sogar als einzelne Spieler solche Fights mit
entscheiden, zum Beispiel versuche ich jetzt mal ein bisschen zu erklären, zum Beispiel wenn man
so einen Turm einnimmt und es haben sich eben Turm oben beim Boss Spieler verschanzt, also die
können mit der halben Anzahl der Leute diesen Turm verteidigen, wenn sie es gut machen gegen uns,
was man dann allerdings machen kann ist, wenn man eine Gruppe hat, die das gut timet, kann man mit
dieser Fähigkeit hier durchrennen aufs Dach und wenn man auf dem Dach ist, können die Leute dann
können die dich nicht mehr killen auf dem Dach, weil alle mit Belagerungswaffen aufs Dach schießen
können und du kannst von oben quasi die ganze Backline kaputt machen von den Gegnern, also das
sind so Sachen, die bringen wirklich was, auch wenn es nicht so aussieht, als könnte man hier mit
wenig Spielern was ausrichten und noch mal so ein Beispiel, wie man auch als einzelner Spieler
Fights mit entscheiden kann, das hängt jetzt aber wirklich ganz entscheidend von der Klasse ab,
also was ich hier spiele, ich spiele ja quasi Skalde, das ist so die Speedklasse in Midgard,
also ich habe Speed, dass wir schneller rennen können, ja also ich kann jetzt solo nicht wirklich
was machen, ich kann hier mal meine Fähigkeit klicken und wir können durch aufs Dach rennen
als Achtergruppe, das geht, aber wo du wirklich Fights entscheiden kannst, ist zum Beispiel als
Heiler, wenn du Heiler bist und den passenden CC setzt, weil man muss dazu sagen, in Dao-Camp
spells keine Targetbegrenzung, also wenn du einen Area-Spell castest, dann wirkt der auf alle,
also sprich, wenn ich mich jetzt hier in den Pulk stelle und irgendjemand castet hier in den
Area-Spell drauf, das trifft alle, die da drinne stehen und also wenn ein Heiler passendes CC setzt
an der richtigen Stelle oder wenn ein Heiler mit, der hat so einen Spruch mit richtig großer
Reichweite, alle Gegner unterbricht oder am Zaubern hindert, sorgt das teilweise schon dafür,
dass durch einen Heiler der Fight gewonnen wird. Follow MLS, Dankeschön für den Sub.
ThirdMagicEye fragt, wie ist der Anführer denn zu seinem Rank gekommen, dass der Rest der Gruppe
oder der ganze Server seinen Befehlen folgt, ja da musst du der richtige Typ für sein.
Polemo hat das gut gemacht, Polemo spielt schon seit einer ganzen Weile auf Free Shards und hat
sich so eine gewisse Following quasi aufgebaut, Leute die wissen, dass die BGs von ihm gut laufen
und er scheißt halt auch permanent die Spiele an die Kacke bauen, also der ist, ich will sagen,
der ist geliebt und gehasst ja, ich finde es immer Entertainment pur, Polemo ist der Hauptgrund,
dass ich hier in diesem Reich auf diesem Server spiele, ich finde das immer super unterhalten und
da macht es auch gut. Ja hauptsächlich weil er schon seit Jahren lang gut macht, dann wissen
die Leute halt, ey da kannst du mit und das funktioniert in der Regel, sieht man ja hier
auch wieder, wir haben alles vernichtet nach dem Anfang, alles vernichtet heute Abend und ansonsten
er hat keinen speziellen Ingame-Rang oder so, das ist rein, man kennt ihn halt und alle machen das
und wenn du das nicht machst, wenn du nicht machst was er sagt, flippt er teilweise übelst aus. Ich
habe letztens einen Clip im Discord gepostet, er ist halt komplett ausgerastet, aber gut,
er hat recht, also meistens hat er recht, das kommt ja auch noch dabei, dass die meisten Sachen,
die er sagt, sinnvoll sind und wenn die Leute sich blöde, wenn die blöde spielen und angeschissen
werden, hat er meistens recht. Manchmal flamet er auch unsinnig rum, weil er schlecht drauf ist,
aber meistens hat er recht. Hast du auch mal als Delsa an Brücken gespielt, war damals Kuni mit
Bogen und Einharschild, war mega. Nein, ich hab fast alles in Dark schon gespielt, außer so Heavy Tank
mit Schild und Zweihand, also sowas wie Krieger oder Armsman oder Fjarn oder so habe ich nicht
gespielt und Delsa. Ich habe eine Weile Mine gespielt, aber Delsa habe ich nie gespielt.
So Schleicher in dem Spiel ist was komplett eigenes, so ein komplett eigenes Game für sich.
Hey Delsa habe ich nie gespielt. Leute, seriously, wie könnt ihr denn da. Wie sie sterben da vorne
wieder. Gut, die wurden von irgendwelchen Belagerungswaffen am Tor gerade gekillt,
da kannst du nicht so viel machen. Ihr habt ja gesehen, die waren instant tot. Also die Gegner
können mit Belagerungswaffen da drauf schießen, aber trotzdem, da sollte man jetzt nicht unbedingt
sterben. Wir hauen ein paar Wachen um. Das war böse, ja. Was sollen wir jetzt eigentlich machen?
Gehen wir jetzt wieder oder gehen wir jetzt ran oder? Okay, der große Meister ist sich
noch nicht ganz einig, was wir machen sollen. Ja, bei der Gelegenheit kann ich euch noch mal
kurz die Skills zeigen und dann werdet ihr feststellen, Leute, nicht sterben, please.
Passt doch mal ein bisschen auf. Ich habe überhaupt keinen Grund da rein zu pushen,
solange wir nicht pushen sollen. Ich kann euch mal kurz die Skills zeigen. Also jede Klasse hat,
wenn ihr levelt, meistens 3-5 Skillbäume und darauf kann man Punkte verteilen. Auf den
unterschiedlichen Skilllinien gibt es halt, wer hätte das gedacht, Skills oder eben Nahkampf,
Nahkampfangriffe und Skalde ist relativ übersichtlich. Ich habe nicht sonderlich
viele spells und ich habe auch nicht sonderlich viele Angriffe. Übrigens Schwert, ich sage es
nochmal, Schwert ist die schlechteste Waffenlinie in dem Game. Ich würde es nicht specken,
auch wenn ich es hier gespeckt habe. Wenn man andere Klassen spielt, zum Beispiel Heiler,
da hast du hier bei Magiefähigkeiten 6 Reihen mit jeweils so einem langen Ding. Da reichen dir die
ganzen Quickbars, wenn du Heiler spielst, gar nicht. So, können wir jetzt pushen? Sollen wir
jetzt pushen? Ich setze mich mal in die Ramme und ramme eine Runde mit. Ich ramme nicht,
oh Alter. Leute, Heiler, heilen, let's go. Jetzt bin ich dead.
Jetzt mich auf, let's go. Wieder am Start. 3 Head Aktion. Ich gehe da nicht mehr ran jetzt.
Gibt es nur wieder auf den Sack. Ach übrigens, wenn die so einen Zzz über dem Kopf haben,
dann können sie sich für ein paar Sekunden nicht bewegen. So, Keepgate 78%. Hält sich ja in Grenzen.
Ich mache jetzt einfach nichts, kann nichts machen. Wenn ich ans Tor rangehe, sterbe ich und irgendwie
pusht auch sonst keiner. Also, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, was wir eigentlich jetzt genau... Wo
ist denn unser großer Meister? Da ist er, hier irgendwo. Nee, da steht er doch. Stick. Okay,
wir sollen sticken. Das sollte man auch möglichst schnell machen, sonst gibt es Ärger.
Ich hoffe, es sind alle weg vom Keep. Ja, sieht gut aus. Alle weg. Okay, gut. Was haben wir denn
jetzt vor? Ich weiß es nicht so genau. Ja, wie gesagt, wenn wir mit BG FVR fertig sind,
eigentlich wollte ich schon längst off. Ich denke mal, spätestens 23 Uhr oder so ist dann Schluss.
Ich zeige euch da noch mal ganz kurz ein paar andere Sachen von dem Game. Ich zeige euch mal
ein bisschen die Klassen und wie das ein bisschen sonst so aussieht, weil ich gebe zu,
das ist bestimmt super verwirrend für jemand, der mit dem Spiel nichts am Hut hat. Mein Speed ist
kaputt. Okay, ich habe keine Ahnung, was wir hier für Pirouetten drehen gerade.
Weiß auch nicht, was wir jetzt genau vorhaben, aber wir werden erfahren, was sich der Meister
ausgedacht hat. Da unten ist mein Questlock, das könnte ich eigentlich mal wegmachen. Warum
habe ich da mein Questlock unten? Auch mal nicht. Oh, Alps, gib ihn. Jetzt werden sie gefickt und ich bin CC'd. Nice. Jetzt kann ich nichts machen.
Beste. Oh, jetzt kriegen sie auf den Sack. Aber richtig kriegen sie auf den Sack.
Hier geblieben, hier geblieben. Bleibst du hier. Bashen. All next. Voll rein pushen.
Volle Pulle rein. Gib ihm. Dead. Einfach alles mal anhitten für Punkte. Ich kille gar keine Gegner
mehr. Ich renne einfach weiter und hitte alles mal anders. Oh, guck mal, Stels, da versteckt er
sich. Nein, nein, man sieht dich überhaupt nicht hinter dem Baum. Ausgeschlossen. Du bist quasi
unsichtbar. Stelske. Hannes, danke schön für den Sub. Habt ihr ihn auch nicht gesehen, Leute?
Er war komplett unsichtbar hinter dem Baum. Alles tot? Alles tot. Nee, nicht alles tot. Da ist was.
Hinterher. Gib ihm. Oh, oh, oh. Wir sollten nicht so. Nee, komm, da geh ich nicht hinterher. Alter,
wie viele. Guckt euch das im Wasser an, man. Guckt mal, wie viele mit. Von unten, vom Grund,
bis an die Wasseroberfläche. Das sind locker 150 Leute gerade auf einen. Oh, da sind noch mehr.
Gib ihm. Drauf, Leute. Volle Pulle. In your face. Auf, auf. Bam. Stehen bleiben, stehen bleiben.
Mist, keine Range mehr. Okay, guck mal, wie sie alle dahin pushen, obwohl wir da lang pushen
sollten. Egal, die holen wir uns jetzt. Die will ich, die will ich haben. Die will ich haben. Gib
ihm. Ich lass den sogar stehen. Na, egal. Nee, ich haut drauf. Ich hab ihn im Mob gepullt noch.
Okay, ich verpiss mich wieder. So, alleine ist immer schlecht, weil die 150 Gegner könnten
direkt um die Ecke sein. Boah, wie viele. Also ohne Mist, Leute, das ist selten. Das ist wirklich
selten, dass es so viele Leute in der BG hat. Das sind noch ein paar. Das sind wieder welche.
All die Alps, die lernen es nicht, oder? Die lernen es nicht. Die wollen sich abfarben lassen
gerade. Alles dead. Alles dead. Ich hoffe, ich hoffe, wir haben einen VR-Task geholt.
Nö, haben wir nicht. Gut. Das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt die hohe Kunst, mit 160 Leuten 20
umzuzergen. Was hast du da wieder für eine Free-2-Play-Perle gefunden? Das ist Dark Age of
Kamenor. Das ist eines der Kult-MMOs schlechthin, spiele ich seit 20 Jahren. Das ist mit dem besten
und dem einzigartigsten PvP, was es überhaupt gibt bei MMOs. Du kannst es aktuell aber tatsächlich
Free-2-Play spielen auf einem Free-Shart. Oh, das... Jawoll, lasst mich, hau mich raus.
Macht den Tangler kaputt. Rein hier. Rein. Die müssen jetzt dran glauben. Damn. Pushen,
pushen, pushen, pushen. Next. Snaren. Ruf. Pushen. Gib ihm, pushen. Die ganzen Luris.
Alles dead. Alles dead. So muss es sein. So mag ich das. Mal kurz stats gucken, ob der
Samen sich irgendwie gelohnt hat. Naja, 7k die Stunde ist jetzt nicht so geil. 15, 15k
gemacht. Ah gut, für das, dass wir am Anfang so auf den Sack gekriegt haben und eigentlich
so richtig erst seit einer Stunde gute Fights sind, ist das schon okay. Okay, 7k die Stunde
ist eigentlich auch totaler Blödsinn, weil, stimmt überhaupt nicht, ich hab zwei Stunden
rumgestanden vorher, ohne was zu machen. Also insofern... Ja. Das kann nicht so schlecht
sein. Weiter. Oh, da sind die Franzosen wieder. So, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, was wir vorhaben.
Mein, wir sind jetzt ein paar Mal hin und her gerannt und haben jedes Mal die Gegner
gereckt. Sind da wieder noch? Nee, oder? Da sind ja wieder welche. Spawnen die hier irgendwo
oder was ist da los? Ja, ich glaub die Gegner spawnen hier irgendwie. Nameplates? Irgendwie
sind die ein bisschen... You cannot use this command in combat? Was? Ah ja, okay. Bist
mir neu, dass man das nicht in combat benutzen kann. Du hast gerade auf hip den Drachen gekillt
mit 300 Leute in der BG. Ja, das haben wir auf Midcard auch. Wir haben Leute, die machen
irgendwie den ganzen Tag PvE, irgendwie in BGs mit 300 Leuten und wenn dann RVR oder
PvP was geht, hauen sie auf einmal alle ab und dann bleibst du dann mit 50 übrig. Aber
ich meine, jeder wie er spielen will. Du kannst Starhawk ja auch auf verschiedene Arten spielen.
Du kannst theoretisch auch den ganzen Tag PvE und Craften, wobei ich sagen muss, also
Dark ist jetzt nicht unbedingt das Spiel, wo man als reiner PvE-Spieler und Crafter
glücklich wird. Es hat ein paar ganz coole Sachen für zwischendurch und macht auch
immer mal wieder Bock zwischendurch, aber hauptsächlich musst du PvP mögen in Dark,
sonst macht es eigentlich keinen Sinn. Ich glaube die Gegner haben aufgegeben oder? Die
werden seit einer Stunde einfach nur noch komplett zerstört und trauen sich gar nicht mehr raus,
aber mein Chat hat ja gerade geschrieben, es waren gerade 300 Hips beim Drache,
also vielleicht kommen jetzt auch gleich wieder mehr. Was ist das hier? Ah, Mids. Boah, sind das
viele Mann. Guckt euch das an. So viele Mids. Ich sag's nochmal, falls irgendjemand Bock hat,
sich das Game anzugucken, ihr könnt es kostenlos zur Zeit spielen. Was heißt zur Zeit? Immer,
gibt eigentlich immer Free Shards, ihr geht einfach auf eden-dark.net, könnt einen Account
anlegen, aktuell spielen gerade 2700 Leute, relativ ausgeglichen, könnt einen Account anlegen,
also im Prinzip müsst ihr euch eigentlich einfach nur mit Discord einloggen und euch
autonifizieren, dass es euer Account ist und dann könnt ihr das Spiel runterladen und patchen und
los spielen, also es dauert zwei Minuten könnt ihr spielen. Dark ist allerdings ein Spiel,
was nicht jetzt so easy ist zum Einstieg, also das Spiel ist alt, das Spiel hat relativ viele
Mechanics, die nicht so gut vielleicht für Noobs verständlich sind. Mal kurz was trinken.
Oh, ich hab nix mehr zu trinken, da. Was ist da los? Leute, ich hol mal kurz was zu trinken.
Okay, wieder am Start. Wieder am Start. Ich muss von HydratedStain hier. Ja, es ist schon spät,
es ist schon spät, aber ich hab hier morgen frei, es ist halb so wild. Also es kann doch sein,
dass meine Crew jetzt off gehen möchte, das kann auch durchaus sein, wenn die
off gehen wollen dann. Dann machen wir Schluss, ich suche jetzt keine neuen Leute zum Spielen.
Oh, oh, die Alps kommen, die Alps kommen. Okay, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob wir schnell genug
in den Turm kommen. Da könnt ihr mal Turm-Defense sehen, ihr werdet nichts blicken,
ich muss auf jeden Fall die Effekte ausmachen. Schnell auf, schnell, schnell, schnell auf,
sonst assjammen die uns, Gachibas von hinten. Wird dann reingefahren hier vom Alpsherk.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ob wir den Boss killen sollen oder nicht. Hab jetzt nicht geguckt.
Ich geh mal aufs Dach schauen, ob die Alps kommen. Noch sieht man nix.
Oh, wir können bisschen Armbrust schießen. Noch, noch nix zu sehen. Nix zu sehen. Jetzt mach
ich mal was, was alle Heiler hassen. Ich hab auch lange genug Support gespielt,
nämlich vom Dach springen, wieder runter. Jetzt denken sie immer, oh nein, der Max stirbt,
schnell instanti. Ich hab das immer gehasst, wenn ich Heiler gespielt hab. Wenn die Leute
vom Turm oder vom Keep gesprungen sind, weil sie zu faul sind, die Treppe zu laufen oder
durch die Tür zu gehen. Die mögen das überhaupt nicht.
Ich bin jetzt wirklich mal gespannt, was eigentlich, was der große Masterplan ist,
frage ich mich gerade. Es gibt übrigens einen PVP, es gibt zwei, stimmt gar nicht ein. Es gibt
zwei PVP Dungeons. Es gibt einmal im Grenzgebiet, hier gibt es die POC, das Ding hier unten,
das soll ein Dungeon darstellen. Das ist ein PVP Dungeon, da hat quasi jedes Reich in seinem
Grenzgebiet so ein Eingang zu, POC. In der Mitte gibt es ein Gebiet, wo Mops sind mit ganz guten
Drops und Equipment. Und dann gibt es als eigentlich das Beste vom Game, gibt es noch
Darkness Falls, das ist auch ein PVP Dungeon. Da können wir nachher mal kurz, wobei weiß
ich, ob es sinnvoll ist, da rein zu gucken. Solo eher nicht, da ist jetzt wahrscheinlich
gar nichts los. Gucken wir mal, Darkness Falls sind 36 Leute, naja geht. Und ich muss sagen,
Dungeon PVP ist eines der spaßigsten Sachen, was es in Dark gibt. Ich meine nicht, dass
hier Grenzgebiete auch nice sind, aber Dungeon PVP ist teilweise richtig nice. Ja, du machst
da drin irgendwas, du farmst Siegel oder farmst Gold oder killst Bosse und auf einmal tauchen
irgendwelche Gegner auf und musst dann mitten im Pool quasi mit den Gegnern fighten. Oh,
ich bin durchs Öl gestorben. Oh, oh, oh, oh, jetzt gibt es Ärger. Hoffentlich hat
es der große Meister nicht gesehen, dass ich am Öl gestorben bin, wenn ich direkt auf
Wanliste. Aber zum Glück ist ja unsere Heile auf, zack. Da kann ja eigentlich nichts passieren.
Guck hier, so muss das sein. Gerät direkt neu gebufft, alles wieder gut. Ich bin immer
noch unschlüssig, was wir genau vorhaben. Bin ich eigentlich bald mal 5x8? Nee, dauert
noch. Und wieder hin. Okay, den schnappen wir und dann ist er down. Nochmal renne ich
nicht unter die Ramme, äh unter das Öl, weil falls ihr es vielleicht nicht gesehen
habt, am Keep vorne hier an den sind zwei Ölkessel. Guck mal da, da ist ein Ölkessel
und da ist ein Ölkessel. Und wenn man, Achtung, Achtung, Achtung, Achtung, dead. Habt ihr es
gesehen? Lul. Und wenn man nicht aufpasst, ist man relativ schnell tot von dem Öl, so
wie die zwei Dudes da vorne jetzt zum Beispiel. Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, shit, ich hab nur noch
Pudge eins, shit, shit, shit, shit, shit, shit, weg, weg, ganz schnell weg. Ja, ich muss unbedingt
wieder Pudge zwei skilln. What the, wo stirbt denn der Dude? Wo ist er, wo ist er dead? Am
Keep. Alter, was ist wieder mit unseren Leuten in der Gruppe los? Warum sterben die mal so
was, man? Gibt's doch nicht. Weg, weg, weg, weg, weg hier. Also eins kannst du bei BGR
vorher nicht irgendwie hinterher hängen, weil wenn du hinterher hängst, bist du immer
dead. Immer. Guck, alle die hinterher hängen sind dead. Die sterben schon hier hinten.
Seht ihr das? Hinterher hängen, dead. Du hast das gesuchtet vor 20 Jahren, ja ich auch,
nur dass ich das immer noch regelmäßig spiele. Allerdings nicht auf einem offiziellen Server,
sondern auf einem, auf einem FreeShart. Eden-Dawg.net, falls du dir das nochmal angucken willst. Alps
hießen früher Dosen. Haha, stimmt. Ja, wir hatten, stimmt, Dawg in Deutschland hatte
so ein paar ganz, so ein paar ganz spezielle Wörter, ja. Wo ist er, wo ist er, wo ist
er, kommst du her? Hier geblieben, hier geblieben, so nicht. Ja, Dawg in Deutschland hatte so
ein paar ganz komische Wörter. Alps waren Dosen, Hips, äh Mids waren Stinker, Hips
weiß ich jetzt gar nicht mehr. Also, ja, teilweise hatten wir in Deutschland, in Dawg
echt richtige Cringe Begriffe. Mittlerweile habe ich mich aber an die, an die Internationalen
gewöhnt. Boah, ich muss unbedingt mehr trinken, ich habe jetzt zwei Stunden geschmetzt, ohne
was zu trinken, ich merke das im Hals. Generell, ihr müsst mich öfter dran erinnern, wenn
ich streame. Auch bei den anderen Streams, ihr müsst mich öfter dran erinnern, wenn
ich was trinke. Ich trinke teilweise viel zu wenig im Stream. Das merke ich dann am anderen
Tag morgens, so nach dem Motto, ah ja, gestern wieder fünf Stunden Stream geschmetzt. Wer
ist raus? Ah, der Typ, der immer stirbt, ist raus. Okay, ja, dann sollten sie jemand anderes
einladen. So, was man jetzt schon ganz gut sieht, ist, wenn ihr euch jetzt mal hier die
Karte anguckt, die eine Festung gehört in Alps, die gehört uns, hier haben sie Türme verloren
an beiden Festungen, das heißt, wir können jetzt relativ easy ins Hinterland hier und
versuchen irgendwelche von denen Festungen einzunehmen, weil die können nicht mal vorne
hin porten, die können hier auch nicht hin porten, das heißt, die müssen jetzt von
daheim laufen. Ah, okay, danach ist die Gruppe, wir hören gleich auf. Ja, wir hören gleich
auf. Vielleicht laufe ich auch noch ein Stückchen mit dann solo und guck mal, ob irgendwas geht
oder mal gucken. Mal gucken. In einem späteren Patch war Labyrinth auch gut. Ja, Labyrinth
gibt es hier nicht, Labyrinth ist deaktiviert, was ich auch ganz gut finde, ehrlich gesagt,
ich fand das Labyrinth nie so geil. Aber ja, natürlich, der hätte ja noch mal einen richtig
großen weiteren FVR-Dungeon, PVP-Dungeon gehabt. Musst du ins Bett, hast du Urlaub?
Nee, ich hab frei morgen, ich hab montags immer frei. Ich hab immer frei. Wir haben
übrigens ein neues Emote. Guck mal, wir haben jetzt Wupps Sleeper. Wir haben jetzt zwei Betge-Emotes.
Ja, und wenn wir fertig sind, werde ich euch noch mal kurz ein bisschen was sonst zeigen
dazu, weil das hier ist natürlich schon für Leute, die das noch nie gespielt haben, äußerst,
äußerst wir. Auge juckt. Ich zeige euch da noch mal so ein bisschen, was es sonst noch
gibt und mal so die Klassen, was es gibt, falls irgendjemand wirklich Bock hat, sich
das mal anzugucken. Also wie gesagt, es ist kostenlos, Spieler, kann es eigentlich nicht
genug geben, weil solche Server leben natürlich nur, Lots of Alps are coming, solche Server
leben natürlich nur, solange es Spieler gibt. Wobei ich sagen muss, eben, also der Free Start,
der Free Shot, auf dem wir gerade spielen, ist tatsächlich der erste Free Shot, von dem
ich denke, die machen es richtig. Bisher haben die ganzen Free Shots immer versucht, die
offiziellen Server zu imitieren. Und so nach dem Motto, lange Procrashing, Server ausgelegt
für eins, zwei Jahre, das klappt in der Regel eigentlich nicht. Und Eden macht es jetzt
zum ersten Mal richtig, die wollen das mit Seasons machen, also quasi eine Season, geht
drei, vier, fünf Monate lang und dann gibt es eine kurze Downtime, ich glaube, irgendwie
so wollen sie, Bam, Gegner, Gegner baschen. Dann gibt es eine kurze Downtime und dann
gibt es eine neue Season, alle fangen wieder bei Level 1 an. Und es gibt dann Patches,
was die Season dann wieder ein bisschen interessanter macht. Also die ändern dann ein bisschen
Sachen von Season zu Season. Was finde ich, das finde ich ist cool, weil ganz ehrlich,
Daug ist 20 Jahre alt und auch wenn sich da immer mal was geändert hat, man hat sich
irgendwann auch an dem Standard so ein bisschen satt gespielt, deswegen finde ich das mit
den Seasons genau richtig. Also du kannst jetzt durchsuchten, eins, zwei, drei Monate,
dann machst du wieder ein bisschen Pause und dann spielst du die nächste Season mit
ein paar Änderungen. Ich laufe jetzt hier noch mal mit, mal gucken, wo er hin will.
Guck mal, da ist ein Gegner, der will umgezerkt werden. Zack, habe ich den gekillt? Death's
Flow, so muss das sein. Erstmal mit DDS-Folge spammt. Hips waren Baumkuschle, war das so?
Kann ich mich gar nicht mehr dran erinnern. Ich weiß nur, dass Alps Dosen waren auf Deutsch
und Mids waren Stinker. Kann schon sein. Das kann schon sein. Wir kommen jetzt aber gefährlich
nahe ans gegnerische Relikt schon, wenn ich das hier angucke. Ich hau jetzt aber gleich
ab. Die Leute machen Ausschluss. Guck, also 23 Uhr, die müssen auch alle Bedge machen,
Bedge-Time. Ich mach jetzt noch den nächsten Turm mit und vibe mich dann am Keep. Ja, anscheinend
ist der Turm jetzt dran. Ich geh mich jetzt viben, Leute. Disband. Ich geh mich mal kurz
viben und dann zeige ich euch noch mal kurz die Klassen und ein bisschen sonst noch was
zu machen kann. Das RVR ist einzigartig korrekt. Das ist das beste PvP-Spiel. Allein schon
durch die Dynamik. Dadurch, dass du drei verschiedene Reiche hast, ist es einfach ungeschlagen
in der Dynamik, was das PvP angeht. Ich werd mich jetzt mal kurz viben hier. Aufkillt mich
mal, Wachen. Hinsetzen für mehr Damage. Nice. Okay, Release. Das ist wie in Guild Wars.
Guild Wars 2 hat sich sehr viel abgeguckt davon. Aber ich finde es trotzdem immer noch ungeschlagen,
vor allem, weil es eben super integriert ist. In Guild Wars gibt es ja unterschiedliche
Skills für PvE und PvM. Hier ist alles das gleiche. Du hast die gleiche Ausrüstung und
die gleichen Skills im PvE und im PvM. Du kannst deine Fähigkeiten im PvE und PvM
einsetzen. In Guild Wars 2 hat sich vieles abgeguckt, aber ich finde Dark macht es immer
noch besser. Und wenn wir Glück haben, kommt vielleicht noch irgendwann null Camelot Unchained,
was ich nicht glaube. Die haben uns ja richtig gescampt. So, jetzt porte ich mal kurz bei
uns in die Stadt. Und dann zeige ich euch noch ein bisschen was zu den Klassen, bevor
ich aufgehe. So, Viertelstunde, 20 Minuten habe ich noch Zeit, denke ich. So, sind wir
in der Stadt. Die Donnerkrieger. Ja, Donnerkrieger haben sie in Deutsch immer Döner genannt.
Dönerkrieger. Ich sage, Dark hatte schon ein paar richtig Cringe Begriffe auf Deutsch.
So, hier, Start, Starting Town. So, also was kann ich euch über das Game erzählen? Wie
gesagt, nachdem wir jetzt nicht ins PvP rumrennen, kann ich vielleicht noch ein paar Takte dazu
sagen. Also, das ist ein Custom Server, muss man auch ganz klar erwähnen. Also viele Sachen
sind hier nicht wie auf Live. Zum Beispiel, dass hier Buff NPCs rumstehen und sowas, dass
man Solo auch ganz gut auskillen kann, sind nicht wie auf Live. Ansonsten, wer Bock hat
das Spiel zu spielen, das erste was ihr machen müsst, ihr müsst euch, ich logge mal kurz
in den, ja sieht schon deutlich besser aus, wenn man die Effekte anschaltet. So, ich zeige
euch jetzt mal was. Also, falls ihr irgendwie Bock habt zu spielen, das erste was ihr machen
müsst ist, ihr müsst euch entscheiden, wo ihr spielen wollt. Also, entweder wollt ihr
Albion spielen. Wenn man auf mittelalterliches England steht, ist das, das wird man von der
Grafik nicht so sehr, nicht so sehr schocken. Also, ihr müsst euch überlegen, wollt ihr
Albion, Hibernia oder Midgard spielen. Midgard ist quasi so skandinavisch angehaucht, das
eher so keltisch und das ist halt mittelalterliches England. Gibt es überall unterschiedliche
Klassen. Sekunde. Ich muss die Musik mal wieder von vorne starten. Ist mir zu actionreich
jetzt. Du hast, ähm, create, create new character. Ja, für die ganzen, also übrigens es gibt
auch bessere Grafik für die Models, aber ich mag die neuen Models nicht. Da sehen
die Models besser aus, aber naja gut. Also, ihr seht, ihr habt jetzt 1, 2, 3, äh 1, 2,
3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15, die Klassen gibt es nicht. Also, irgendwie
für 12, 12 Klassen zur Auswahl. Ungefähr in jedem Reich ist das ungefähr das gleiche.
Ihr habt, äh, ich glaub, komische Kühe, die gibt es hier glaub ich auch nicht. Ihr
habt verschiedene, ihr habt verschiedene Races zur Auswahl und die sind halt unterschiedlich
gut für unterschiedliche Zwecke. Ja, ihr könnt beispielsweise Cobalt spielen, das ist ein
relativ guter, guter Bone Dancer und Caster und sowas in der Richtung. Also erstens, ihr
müsst euch einen Reich aussuchen und Character erstellen, den ihr spielen wollt und gut
ist. Ja, genau Eden Dark kannst du, kannst du gucken. Warte mal, ich zeig's dir, ich
zeig's dir gleich nochmal. Äh, hier Eden, Eden Dark, Eden-Dark.net. Spielen geht auch
wirklich zackig. Du musst dir den offiziellen Client runterladen, den, ihren Patcher, dich
mit Discord anmelden und es funktioniert. So und ich zeig euch mal ganz kurz, äh, Classes
Dark, ob's da eine Übersicht gibt. Ja, gibt sogar eine offizielle, gibt sogar eine offizielle
Übersicht. Boah, also es gibt, es gibt, es gibt total viele Sachen. Ihr müsst euch im
Prinzip das einfach mal angucken, wenn ihr, wenn ihr Bock habt, äh, Bock habt, das zu
spielen. Das Einzige, was ihr euch im Vorfeld ein bisschen überlegen solltet, ist was,
welche Richtung ihr spielen wollt. Also wollt ihr, äh, mehr Caster spielen, wollt ihr
mehr Support, wollt ihr mehr DPS spielen, Range DPS, Melee DPS. Ihr könnt euch aber
alles mal angucken. Es gibt ein Tutorial, das, äh, ist in ungefähr 20 Minuten durchzumachen
und bringt euch bis Level 10. Da könnt ihr quasi die ganzen Klassen euch ein bisschen
angucken. Und ich frag grad, ob's hier eine ordentliche Übersicht gibt, ja. So und man
sieht ja halt, es ist ein bisschen aufgeteilt, immer, immer in Nahkampf, äh, Range Caster,
Schleicher, Support Klassen und sowas. Es ist halt insofern einzigartig, das Game, nicht
nur, dass es drei Reiche gibt, sondern dass die halt komplett unterschiedlich sind. Nicht
nur die Gebiete sind unterschiedlich, auch die Klassen. Also ihr seht ja, kein Reich
hat die gleiche Klasse. Okay, bis auf eine. Ich glaub, die gibt's überall. Ja. Ähm,
ansonsten, es ist alles, es ist alles einzigartig purreich. Also du hast keine Klasse außer
Mauler. Äh, Mauler gibt's hier auf dem Server nicht und zackt eh. Äh, ist doppelt. Natürlich
sind die Rollen überall vorhanden. Also du hast in jedem Reich Heavy Tanks. Hier hast
du einen Krieger. Hier hast du beispielsweise einen, einen Hero. Hier hast du beispielsweise
einen Parler und einen, einen Armsman. Du hast schon ähnliche Rollen, aber die Klassen
sind, ohne Scheiß. Das hab ich so auch noch in keinem Game gesehen. Die Klassen sind alle
unterschiedlich. Also es gibt eigentlich nichts, was gleich ist. Also du kannst jetzt auch
nicht sagen, ey guck mal, hier so, so der Standard-DPS-Caster-Wizard in Albion wäre
mit, wäre mit einem Hunenmeister irgendwie ihn mit zu vergleichen. Ist es nicht. Also
die Klassen sind wirklich alle komplett unterschiedlich. Du hast manchmal so ein paar Parallelen. Du
hast einen Heiler, der kann heilen. Du hast einen, du hast einen Clary und einen Ordenspuder,
der kann heilen. Aber die spielen sich alle anders. Und selbst die Klassen, wo man denkt,
die sind ziemlich ähnlich. Zum Beispiel so die Main Tanks. Main Tanks sind, äh, also
schwerste Rüstung, ordentlich Damage, Nahkampf. Main Tanks ist hier, ist Armsman in Albion,
ist hier Hero in Hip und ist Warrior in Midgard. Aber trotzdem, sogar diese Tanks sind unterschiedlich.
Der Krieger ist der Tank mit den Abstand, mit den meisten HPs. Krieger ist glaube ich
die langweiligste Klasse, finde ich, die es gibt. Krieger hat den höchsten Damage-Modificator
und den höchsten HP-Modificator und ist eigentlich tankmäßig so das Ultimative, was
es gibt. Volle Schild-Spec, volle Zweihandspec für Damage und alles. Dafür haben die anderen
zwei noch gewisse Feinheiten. Der Armsman kann beispielsweise als einzige Klasse im Spiel
so, so Lanzen, Zweihand-Lanzendinger tragen, aber trotzdem ordentlich Einhand- und Schildspecken.
Der Vierer kann sich in irgendeinen Elch verwandeln, hat mehr HPs. Also es ist, auch wenn man denkt,
es ist ähnlich. Und das sind die ähnlichsten Klassen, die es gibt, ja. Die anderen sind
komplett unterschiedlich. Also die Tanks sind tatsächlich noch das Ähnlichste, was
es gibt. Sogar die Tanks sind unterschiedlich. Man kann natürlich, wenn man jetzt viel Krieger
gespielt hat, ohne Probleme auch einen Armsman spielen. Dann hast du beispielsweise einen
Mercenary und hier hast du einen Blademaster, die greifen mit zwei Waffen an. Aber trotzdem,
sie sind alle unterschiedlich. Es hat alle einen gewissen Kniff. Und spätestens bei
den Support-Klassen und bei den Castern ist alles unterschiedlich. Da hast du keine Klasse,
die auch nur ansatzweise ähnlich sind. Die sind alle unterschiedlich. Also deswegen,
man muss sich das Reich aussuchen, wo man spielen will. Und dann halt welche Klasse
man spielen will. Und vielleicht ist es tatsächlich am besten, man sucht hier als erstes das Reich
aus, wo man spielen will, einfach was einem halt thematisch am besten gefällt. Möchte
man grüne Wiese, geht man nach Hibernia. Möchte man Schnee und Berge, geht man nach
Midgard. Möchte man Grün und Wälder und mittelalterliches England, geht man nach Albion.
Wobei ich sagen muss, Albion kackt ein bisschen ab die letzten Wochen auf dem Server, aber
das kann sich immer relativ schnell ändern. Dann gibt es noch in jedem Reich eine eigene
Housing-Zone. Also man kann sich hier, man kann sich Häuser kaufen und man kann sich
Häuser kaufen und eigene Händler hinstellen und Items verkaufen, die man erfarmt hat.
Ich renne jetzt hier einfach mal los, ich gehe mal durch die Housing-Zone durch und
alles was ihr hier seht sind quasi Spieler, wenn man denn was sieht, sind quasi Spielerhäuser.
Wenn ich mal in so einem Dorf angelangt bin, sind Spielerhäuser die, genau, sind alles
Spielerhäuser mit Händlern, wo man dann seine erfarmten Sachen verkaufen kann. Also
wenn man quasi so High-Level PVE-Fan ist, kann man dann seine erfarmten Sachen hier
verkaufen. Der hat nicht wirklich viel drinne. Oder wenn man Crafter ist, kann man beispielsweise
seine Tränke und Fässer und so verkaufen. Ich porte mich mal hier raus. Ja. Ich eigentlich
bin eigentlich gelieft aus Battlecruel. Ich denke das Beste ist, wenn man sich eben das
Reich anguckt, was man am liebsten spielen will. So und jetzt machen wir eine Sache,
jetzt machen wir eine Sache noch. Ich porte mal raus. Ich zeige euch ganz kurz nochmal
den RVR-Dungeon, also den PvP-Dungeon. Dass man es mal gesehen hat. Da kann ich, ich renne
da mal hin. Ich renne mal hin. Also man sieht schon. Midgard, Berge, Schnee. Wobei nicht
alles Berge und Schnee sind. Die haben auch ganz coole Gebiete. Gerade in der Erweiterung
haben die ganz coole Gebiete. Da oben müssen wir hin. DF. DF ist ein PvP-Dungeon. Der hat
eigentlich nur Zugang. Der Realm, der die meisten Outposts, also die meisten, im Grenzgebiet
die meisten Festungen und Türme hat, ist auf dem Server anders. Auf dem Server können
alle, können alle rein. Da rennt ein Low-Level rum. Kann man jetzt erschrecken. Rennen wir
mal ins PvP, äh nicht PvP, rennen wir mal ins PvP-Dungeon rein. Bin ich persönlich das
beste Gebiet am ganzen Spiel. Und gerade wenn du da irgendwas am Farmen bist und geh ich
noch mal kommen. Das ist wirklich, das ist wirklich nice. Also kann man, ist alles der
besten der besten Aspekte an dem Game. Jo. Ansonsten, ich werde gleich noch mal kurz
in SE porten, also in die Erweiterungsgebiete. Man nennt das in dem Spiel Erweiterung. Eigentlich
ist es keine Erweiterung. Es war mal eine Erweiterung 2003 oder so. Mittlerweile ist
das fester Spielbestandteil. Es kam mal als Addon 2003 raus. Gibt noch ein paar neue Gebiete.
Also es gab viele Addons mit neuen Gebieten, aber das erste Addon ist eigentlich das einzige,
wo die Gebiete sinnvoll in das Spiel integriert sind. Gehen wir in den PvP-Dungeon. Oh guck
mal da ist Ciri, die echte. PvP-Dungeon ist für alle ab Level 30. Also du kannst vorher
rein, aber da findest du keine Gegner und keine Monster zum Killen. Also PvP-Dungeon
ist für High-End-Content zum Farmen und zum Leveln richtig gut, wunderbar. Muss mir hier
runter, dass ich nicht so viel Damage kriege. Und dass ich nicht hier gleich... Nee, nee,
nee, Kollege. Kommt ein paar Leute, kommt ein paar Leute, kommt runter gepusht Leute,
kommt runter gepusht. Alter wie viele sind denn da noch? Kommt runter gepusht, runter
gepusht Leute, runter, runter, runter, runter. Fuck. Okay, RIP, RIP, RIP, RIP, RIP, RIP,
RIP, RIP, RIP, RIP. Lop, lop, lop, lop. Nicht sterben, nicht sterben. Blocken, blocken,
blocken, killen, killen, killen. Leute, Leute, halt mich. Irgendwas. Ich hab so, ich hab
kein Heal mehr. Ah, ich werd geheilt, nice. Excellent, excellent. Machen wir erstmal
den Blatt. Ach, das ist ein Fjarn, Alter. Das ist einer mit Schild, lull. Jetzt habt
ihr auch mal ein bisschen Small Scale PvP gesehen. Tja. Das habt ihr euch anders vorgestellt,
hä? Das habt ihr euch anders vorgestellt. Kleinen Pisser da. Sind da vorne noch welche?
Ah, das wird die echte Siri. Und von den, von den Siegeln, die man sich in dem Dungeon
erfarmen kann, kann man sich dann hier bei den Händlern quasi 50er Equipment kaufen,
was man, was man braucht. So, dann gehen wir mal raus hier. Bringt jetzt nichts, wenn ich
da solo runter gehe, wenn's da grad so voll ist. Ich brauch unbedingt Perch 2. Ich freu
mich schon auf Dienstag, wenn's wieder mehr, wenn's wieder mehr Punkte gibt. Ich brauch
unbedingt Perch 2, dass ich, dass ich gegen sowas was machen kann. Was, NFT's? What?
So, ich geh jetzt nochmal schnell in die Erweiterungsgebiete. Ach so, weil ich grad was von Verkaufen erzählt
hab im Stream mit NFT's. Nein, alles rein, rein in-game. Es gibt übrigens auch Reskin-Varianten
von den Waffen und den Rüstungen. Man kann das hier alles reskinnen, wenn man will. Ich
will aber nicht reskinnen, weil, ich hab meine Waffe reskinnt, ja. Meine Waffe hab ich, ansonsten
hab ich nix reskinnt. Sonst sieht man am Ende dann so aus wie der Dude hier, wenn man zu
viel reskinnt hat. So, gehen wir mal hier beispielsweise, gehen wir mal hin. Oh, das
ist quasi nochmal ein zweites, ähm, größeres Gebiet aus, glaub, sechs Untergebiete. Man
kann sowohl hier im klassischen Gebiet, äh, questen und xp'en, als auch hier, oh, nimmt
sich, nimmt sich eigentlich nicht viel. Man muss sagen, in dem Spiel levelt man tatsächlich
am besten in Group. Allerdings auf dem Free-Shot nicht die klassische, wir killen einfach fünf
Stunden am Stück Monster, sondern man macht meistens Quests. Man macht Kill-Quests und
läuft hier quer über die Map und farmt bestimmte Camps ab und levelt eigentlich relativ schnell.
Aber das macht man auch am besten in Gruppe, ja, dass man Heiler dabei hat, ein bisschen
Speed dabei hat. Und da gibt's auch noch jede Menge Gebiete. Ihr seht schon beispielsweise
in manchen, ich bin gerade übrigens falsch geportet, ne, ne, will ich gar nicht, wo ist
der Porter? Äh, in manchen Gebieten gibt es noch 50er PvE, wo ist denn hier was noch?
Äh, da? Ich glaub, da gibt's noch eins. Genau, da gibt's Trollheim und solche Sachen, das
sind 50er, 8 Mann, also Dungeons, die eigentlich für eine Gruppe ausgelegt sind, wo man gutes
Equipment, Geld und Währung und sonst was farmen kann, wenn man da Bock drauf hat mit
8er Group. Das PvE ist gut, insofern, dass es schöne Abwechslung ist für zwischendurch,
aber, also man muss sagen, wenn man wirklich gar keinen Bock auf PvP hat, ist man in Dark
falsch. Auf der anderen Seite, wenn man ganz gerne PvE und PvP macht, kann man damit auch
seinen Spaß haben, aber am besten ist natürlich, man macht gerne PvP und zwischendurch ein
bisschen Abwechslung und macht ein bisschen PvE, ein bisschen Monster klatschen und gut
ist. Es gibt ein Tutorial, wenn ihr neu auf dem Server anfangt. Gibt's ein Tutorial von
Level 1 bis Level 10. Da porte ich jetzt auch gerade mal hin. Also wenn ihr einen neuen
Char macht, werdet ihr hier starten, werdet ihr hier spawnen und dann könnt ihr irgendwelche
Low-Level-Quests machen bis 10 und wenn ihr 10 seid, könnt ihr quasi raus in die große
Welt. Und am besten, ihr hangelt euch an den Kill-Quests, an den Kill-Quests, lange macht
das mit Gruppe, dann lernt ihr euren Char spielen, ihr lernt euren Char ein bisschen in Gruppe
spielen, ihr lernt das Game kennen. Das ist eigentlich am besten. Genau, so sieht's aus.
Alles klar Leute, 23.30 Uhr, ich hab viel zu wenig getrunken im Stream, zweieinhalb Stunden
am Start gewesen. Ich werd jetzt off gehen und ich hoffe euch hat's gefallen, ihr könnt
ja mal in den Chat schreiben, ob's euch gefallen hat. Ich werd wahrscheinlich die nächsten
Tage normal streamen, allerdings ab und zu mal noch, oh jetzt ist das Game abgekackt
auch wunderbar, ab und zu auch noch mal ne Runde Daug, wenn wirklich, wenn gute Fights
sind und wenn was geht, dass wir nicht wieder ne dreiviertel Stunde Keep-Defense und so
komische Dinger haben. Na das muss ja auch nicht sein. Also wir sehen uns bis denn Leute,
thumbs up zu J-R-R. Was? Was? Als nächstes Totally
voll mit